[Musique]
Écadin, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Je suis philosophe.
J'explore particulièrement, j'ai envie
de dire presque exclusivement
la nature des technologies numériques,
leurs caractéristiques, leurs ressorts
économique, leur levier politique,
l'idéologie, les discours qui
accompagnent leur développement, mais
aussi l'impact sur sur les
comportements, sur les conduites, sur
les psychés. plus que jamais, il y a des
effets qui n'avaient pas été envisagés
estimés il y a une dizaine d'années sur
les psychés très importants l'impact et
cela depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années maintenant le temps passe.
J'avais j'ai commencé à la fin des
années 90 avec une revue qui s'appelait
écart et ensuite après des textes
théoriques poétiques et mon premier
essai date de 2009 surveillance globale
et je n'ai cessé au fur et à mesure
livre après livre d'analyser ce qui se
jouait dans les le développement des
technologies le comme je l'ai dit à
l'instant les ressorts économiqu les les
discours qui accompagnaient cela et
l'étendue des conséquences et c'est allé
ensuite avec un livre qui s'appelait la
société de l'inté passion 2 ans plus
tard euh l'humanité augmenté, la vie
algorithmique, la siliconisation du
monde quasiment tous les 2 ans,
l'intelligence artificielle ou l'enjeu
du siècle, l'air de l'individu tyran.
Bref, c'est
on m'a dit récemment,
tu as tu es en train de construire une
œuvre. Mais je crois
peut-être mais je crois que on me l'a
dit en Amérique latine récemment,
je crois je crois que c'est objectif
hein, je fais part d'une d'une d'un
constat, je crois que je suis peut-être
le seul philosophe qui depuis 15 ans et
se soit strictement penché sur ces
enjeuxl d'un point de vue critique et
produit
neuf ouvrages théoriques philosophiques
sur ces enjeux. Et là aujourd'hui, merci
pour votre invitation, je publie mon 9e
essai théorique sur ces enjeux qui ne
cessent d'évoluer et qui ne cessent
d'appeler à et qui devrai appeler
davantage de pensée et de posture
critique et de réflexion théorique sur
des enjeux qui
pour un très grand nombre d'entre nous
dépassent quand même nous dépasse ou
s'impose sans qu'on puisse se prononcer.
Donc on est très content de vous
recevoir, de te recevoir ce soir parce
que cette interview fait partie d'un
cycle de trois interviews qui avait déjà
commencé avec Cédric Vilani mais on a eu
un problème technique s'est remis au
mois de décembre et on a reçu Laurent
Alexandre et toi ce soir. C'est des
points de vue qui sont différents.
C'est disparate.
C'est disparate. C'est c'est pas du tout
en accord. Euh euh nous on a ingurgité
euh le savoir de chacun pour essayer de
comprendre le point de vue de chacun. Et
ce soir, c'est important de t'avoir
encore pour décrire les répercussions
sur les processus créatifs, sur les
connexions entre les humains, le côté
relationnel, les qu'est-ce que ça peut
faire émerger ? Et j'ai une question
pour commencer. Et pourquoi
je n'arrive pas à vous réconcilier tous
autour d'une table ? Quand je discute
avec X Y Z qui s'intéresse à
l'intelligence artificielle ou à autre
chose, connecter à l'intelligence
artificielle, c'est des querelles de
chapelle, c'est personne ne s'écoute,
personne ne partage et c'est forcément
moi qui qui ai raison. Alors, l'avantage
qu'on a ici, c'est que tout le monde se
respecte,
tout le monde échange, même si
physiquement parlant, j'ai pas réussi
encore à vous à vous réunir tous et je
ne perds pas espoir de pouvoir le faire
dans le calme.
Est-ce que ce serait fructueux ? Je ne
suis pas sûr. Mais je ne suis pas sûr.
Je suis très sceptique sur la notion de
débat, mais c'est pas l'enjeu du jour.
D'échange, pas de débat et donc le moins
s'accorder sur un désaccord.
Donc ce soir Éric euh
pourquoi pourquoi avoir commis
la vie spectrale ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
la vie spectrale ?
Alors on va en lire un petit peu ce
soir. Je voudrais que tu me lises la
première page avec les citations de
poètes français. Pourquoi avoir mis des
citations de poètes français ?
De poètes français ?
Ouais. Première page,
je vois euh du Charles Baudler, du
Platon.
et de André Gide. Et je vois quoi
d'autre ?
Ah, des exerges.
Exactement.
C'est pour mettre en perspective
certains enjeux. Il y a
Est-ce que tu peux me les lire ?
Alors, il y a il y a une citation, il y
a quatre exerges qui un peu donnent le
ton qui peuvent signaler plusieurs
points comme ça en mobilisant des
paroles autres que que que la mienne,
que les nôtres. C'est l'exercice de
l'exerg.
Alors, il y a il y en a une de la
première, c'est une de Gunterse
qui est la préface à la 5e édition de
l'obsesscence de l'homme qui est un
livre qui qui est qu'on relit
aujourd'hui parce qu'il avait vu le
la
l'ampleur de la possible menace
nucléaire à son époque au milieu au
milieu des années 50. Heureusement, il a
été démenti, mais la menace plane
toujours, n'est-ce pas ? Et ce qu'il le
préoccupait, c'est que c'est pas ce qui
le préoccupait, ce qui le troublait, ce
qu'il il le disait lui-même. Ce qui
commençait à le rendre presque fou,
c'est qu'on ne se rendait pas compte à
son sens de l'ampleur
de ce qui pouvait advenir. C'està-dire,
c'était arrivé mais ça entrait dans une
sorte de banalité des choses que la que
la menace existe et que ça aille jusqu'à
un oubli de la chose et il a il a donné
un un nom à cela. C'est c'est
l'irreprésentabilité des catastrophes.
C'est très intéressant. Ça m'inspire
L'ir représentabilité suppose que des
choses existent mais que nous manquons
peut-être d'outil de conscience de
discours, de mode d'approche qui nous
qui nous qui ferait que nous serions
plus à même plus en contact plus au fait
de certains phénomènes qui nous
regardent et qui sont d'une extrême
gravité. Alors, je crois que nous vivons
et je vais m'expliquer euh tout au long
de notre d'échange si tu le veux bien,
un moment d'extrême gravité, de très de
très hautes gravité. Alors, ce que dit
Gunter, c'est nous ne sommes pas de
taille à nous mesurer à la perfection de
nos produits et ce que nous produisons
excède notre capacité de de
représentation,
ce que je disais à l'instant, et de
responsabilité. de responsabilité, ça
veut dire comment on s'engage, com
comment individuel et collectivement on
se détermine relativement à des choses
qui nous dépassent, qui s'imposent et
qui peuvent faire planner une menace
pour ce que nous sommes, pour nos vies
et pour nos principes. Le deuxième, je
m'attendais pas à ce que je lique des
exerges, mais je pas être long, je vais
lire rapidement. Aller de baud de l'air,
fusée, ne mépriser la sensibilité de
personne. La sensibilité de chacun,
c'est son génie. Alors si j'ai mis cela,
c'est en regard du processus de
pixelisation sans cesse croissante de
nos existences et de la et du phénomène
de désincarnation corrélaire de nos de
nos de nos de nos existences et des
rapports interpersonnels.
Une troisième, c'est extrait de Platon
de
la République de Platon. Elle est très
courte,
elle est tranchante. elle
elle interpelle
au regard des génératifs dont on va
parler qui est l'objet un des objets
centraux de mon livre, c'est personne
n'honore comme il faut son âme.
Personne n'honore comme il faut son âme.
Car nous avons une âme, nous avons une
richesse infinie. Nous avons, je peux je
peux prolonger ce que dit Platon, nous
avons il y a un génie logé en chacun
d'entre nous.
Et la menace, une des menaces qui qui
qui pointe serait de mépriser le génie
qui est en nous. J'y reviendrai ou de le
mépriser ou de l'étouffer ou de
l'ignorer.
Et la le dernier exerg la dernière
exergue, elle me regarde. C'est c'est un
point d'ironie.
C'est tiré des faux des faux manilleurs
de d'Andréid. Et là, je parle de moi en
mobilisant cette cet exerge. Il est bon
de suivre sa pente pourvu que ce soit en
montant.
C'est un peu toute ma bibliographie
depuis une quinzaine d'années.
Est-ce que l'intelligence artificielle
te fait peur et pourquoi ?
Alors, je crois qu'il faut que nous nous
que nous nous défassions de certaines
catégories.
la peur, l'enthousiasme.
Dès qu'on parle d'intelligence
artificielle
dans les débats, dans la presse, c'est
les avantages, les inconvénients,
une perspective lumineuse,
la fin du monde, la fin de démocratie,
la fin de l'humanité.
Pourquoi il y a ce que ces ces ce
sensnalisme mais aussi ce régime de
confusion qui entoure l'intelligence
artificielle, n'est-ce pas ? Il y a
quelque chose de l'ordre de la
cacophonie de et et encore plus c'est
revenu depuis un an, on en a reparlé
depuis l'avènement de chat GPT dont on
va parler. Il y a eu combien de
discours, de débats ? Il y a beaucoup de
cacophonie et moi je pense que s'il y a
de la cacophonie, du brouillage, c'est
que nous souffrons de définition
et si nous avons une définition claire,
nous comprenons ce à quoi nous avons
affaire et il y a une base de discussion
et d'échange. Et alors là, on peut se
déterminer librement relativement à ce
qu'il se passe. Cette définition,
personne ne la donne, Sky, personne ou
très peu ou de façon lacunaire et pas
précise. Moi, je me suis efforcé, tu
m'avais invité, tu m'avais gentiment
invité en 2018 pour mon livre
L'intelligence artificielle ou l'enjeu
la l'enjeu du siècle sous-titre Anatomie
d'un d'un anti-humanisme radical qui est
paru en 2018 de donner une définition
très claire et je pense que il faut y
revenir parce que on va saisir l'ampleur
de ce qui se joue, la définition de
l'intelligence artificielle
mais plus encore ce qui se joue avec
l'intelligence. artificielle. Ce qu'il
s'est passé depuis une quinzaine
d'années, c'est tout simplement, j'en
avais parlé mais je vais le redire
rapidement,
c'est un nouvel embranchement dans
l'histoire des technologies numériques.
C'est ça l'affaire. C'est-à-dire que
depuis des décennies, la les fonctions
des technologies numériques, ce qu'on
leur demande, ce à quoi elles sont
assignées, c'est euh à la à la collecte
automatisée de données toujours plus
rapide, toujours plus volumineuse,
à au stockage de données automatisé, à
l'indexation, hein, ce que nous faisons
tous, on tape un mot clé, on a affaire à
des corpus en rapport avec ce mot clé,
hein, ou des systèmes d'un point de vue
individuel et collectif qui fonctionne
par mots clés qui ont qui ont accès à
des à des à des corpus en rapport et à
la manipulation à diverses fins de
l'information et à divers à des fins
toujours plus diverses et multiples qui
ont qui sont à l'œuvre depuis une
trentaine d'années et plus encore une
vingtaine d'années et de plus encore une
dizaine d'années depuis l'avènement de
l'économie de la donnée et et des
plateformes. Si ces fonctions elles sont
encore à l'œuvre et plus que jamais la
collecte, le stockage, l'indexation et
la manipulation à diverses fins de
l'information, c'est plus que jamais à
l'œuvre. le grand événement
technologique, technico-économique
juridique juridico-politique, je vais
m'expliquer pourquoi je dis juridico
politique qui est
politico-politique
juridico-politique c'està-dire c'est
juridique et c'est politique c'estàdire
sont nos catégories juridiques et
politiques. Le grand événement qui est à
l'œuvre depuis en très gros le milieu
des années 2000,
c'est
l'intelligence artificielle, c'est
l'apparition d'un nouvel embranchement
et qui octroie une nouvelle fonction,
deux nouvelles fonctions aux
technologies numériques. J'ai presque
envie de dire une nouvelle mission, ça
j'en avais parlé en 2018 mais je le
redis synthétiquement, c'est celle
d'expertiser le réel. Je l'avais dit ça
en 2018, expertiser le réel de plus en
plus en temps réel. Les exemples sont
foisons. J'avais donné le à l'époque et
je ne cesse de revenir sur l'exemple qui
est le plus parlant. Il y en a il y en a
des milliers, il y en a même pas des
milliers. Il y en a il y en a des
milliardes d'exemples. Mais l'exemple à
mon sens le plus parlant, c'est euh et
d'ailleurs c'est lié à cette époque,
milieu des années 2000. Tiens, je pense
à W dont j'avais déjà parlé à l'époque
qui est l'application
de d'analyse du trafic que tout le monde
utilise racheté par Google à une société
israélienne en 2005. C'est des des
capteurs et des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle. Et que font-ils ? Ils
diagnostiquent en temps réel l'état du
trafic à des vitesses infiniment
supérieures à nos capacités cognitives
mais pas seulement. qui récolte des des
données, des informations que n'importe
quel aucun être humain ne serait capable
de de collecter, enfin pas capable ne
serait en mesure de collecter et qui
expertise l'état du trafic mais pas
seulement. Et c'est là la 2e dimension
de l'intelligence artificielle qui est
capitale et on va commencer à comprendre
les incidences politico-juridiques,
c'est que c'est aussi ce sont aussi des
instances, des technologies, des
systèmes qui encouragent d'adopter telle
euh action plutôt que telle autre. Là ce
que fait W ne fait pas il ne fait pas
que seulement de que diagnostiquer. Il
encourage il suggère d'emprunter tel
itinéraire plutôt que tel autre. Et ça
c'est ce que j'ai appelé le tournant
injonctif de la technologie. C'est pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
technique. Moi je parle de technologie.
J'analyse dans le livre le fait qu'on
passe de la technique à la technologie à
partir l'histoire de la machine à
vapeur. C'està-dire l'humain est mise à
distance. Il y a des rouages plus grands
que nous qui font que on passe à la
technologie, c'est-à-dire aux
technico-économiques, c'est-à-dire c'est
principalement des intérêt industriel
qui guide les développements de la
technique. Et le le c'est le moment où
injonctif dans la technique de la
technologie qui voit des systèmes nous
encourager,
nous inciter,
nous prescrire ou nous obliger. il y a
plusieurs niveaux euh à a adopter telle
action que telle autre plutôt que telle
autre. Et ça c'est ce que j'avais
appelé, je le redis, le tournant
injonctif de la technologie dès 2018 en
signalant des seuils, un un seuil que
j'avais appelé incitatif qui s'applique
principalement aux individus,
c'est-à-dire les principalement qui est
à l'œuvre de avec les applications et le
rapport de chacun au système numérique
qui voit des systèmes des des
plateformes analyser nos nos
comportements et nous conseiller en
retour d'agir de telle manière plutôt
que de telle manière. la dimension
spectrale, c'estàd fantômes qui nous
parlent, mais c'est aussi à l'œuvre dans
les dimensions de de de secteur
collectif, des systèmes qui expertise et
qui encourage d'agir de telle manière
plutôt que de telle manière. par exemple
le recrutement qui voit euh euh de plus
en plus des compagnies publier des
annonces de candidature et qui voient
des des cabinets de recrutement utiliser
des chatbot audio ou vidéo et euh
dialoguer hein dialoguer le la dimension
anthropomorphique est un grand enjeu de
de la technologie
qui va nous mener au gouffre mais j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure et qui voit
des systèmes
qui fonctionne par audio vidéo,
dialoguer avec les les candidats et
expertiser la qualité supposée selon des
critères dont on ne sait pas grand-chose
mais don on peut supposer que c'est la
plus grande docilité, la plus grande
réactivité, la plus grand
de l'iris,
toute une série de choses et qui signale
sur 300 candidats les 4 5 6 candidats à
sélectionner, qui les sélectionne et qui
voit des humains en 2023 dans la boucle,
les rencontrés deu euh en 2023, mais en
2030 euh on peut supposer que c'est des
systèmes qui disent les choses et euh
cette cette dimension d'expertise
et d'orientation
de l'action humaine,
je veux pas refaire le notre entretien
de 2018, mais ce qui doit être souligné,
c'est que
C'est c'est ça se à l'œuvre en vue de
deux fins principales seulement deux
fins. Il y en a pas 36, il y en a de
fin. C'est cela qu'il faut voir. C'est
quand on parle d'intelligence
artificielle, c'est bien, c'est la
catastrophe, c'est la un monde lumineux.
Il y a deux perspectives principales
pour toi.
C'est pour moi mais c'est les analyses
objectives que j'ai faites à coup de de
cas de figure et et ça c'est des choses
que j'ai théorisé dès 2017-28 hein et
que je reprends un nouveau frais dans ce
livre sauf que j'associe à la
pixelisation croissante de nos
existences qui avaient été nommé métav
et à la l'émergence des des génératives.
Mais
ce qui la l'intention
les projets qui se développent en
s'adant sur cette systématique
d'interprétation et de recommandation
automatisée de l'action humaine, c'est
deux choses. ce que j'ai appelé
d'une part que j'ai appelé dès 2014 ou
2015 la marchandisation intégrale de la
vie, c'est-à-dire cette cette
systématique de d'interprétation
recommandation
des comportements, des conduites, hein,
des des des applis vous vous
comprennent, vous interprètent ou des
enceintes connectées reliées à des à des
grands groupes de la donnée vous
connaissent de plus en plus et vous
parlent euh tournant injonctif ou
incitatif, technologie qui nous orient,
qui sont des technologies de la
prétendue supériorité de nous-même,
sachant ce qui est supposé être bon pour
pour chacun de nous, pour ce qui pour ce
qui regarde les individus. Donc le
premier objectif, c'est d'organiser,
d'entraîner
une marchandisation intégrale de la vie
mais en faisant disparaître
le fait, le l'existence, le la présence
de de groupes, de techniques
qui seraient qui aurait été jusque-là
destiné à orienter nos comportements. Je
pense au marketing, je pense à la
publicité.
Là, nous allons, c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé le livre euh la vie spectrale. Il
y a quelque chose de spectral, de
fantômes qui nous accompagnent, qui nous
parlent, qui nous disent.
Et c'est un
nous avons affaire à un mécanisme qui
euh qui se naturalise. D'ailleurs, ça
nous parle hein, ça nous parle qui se
naturalise dans la compréhension
et ce que j'avais appelé depuis un
certain nombre d'années, je suis désolé
de me citer mais cétait c'est à l'œuvre
depuis une dizaine d'années,
l'accompagnement algorithmique de la
vie, c'est des systèmes qui ne cessent
de nous accompagner en vue d'engager la
bonne action prétendue. Je je signale à
ce sujet que Google en mai 2023, donc il
y a 6 mois,
a signalé travaillé sur un système, mais
c'est déjà à l'œuvre pour toute
l'industrie numérique depuis fort
longtemps, depuis le le l'assistant
numérique personnalisé Siri depuis 2010
a délibérément et sans sans jeûne
affirmer travailler un système nous
donnant des des conseils les plus
judicieux
le long du quotidien. hein, c'est ça
cette logique, ce mécanisme qui est à
l'œuvre depuis euh
en gros depuis le euh l'avènement de de
l'intelligence artificielle dans sa
forme ultra sophistiquée qui est à
l'œuvre depuis la fin des années 2000 et
avec l'avènement de de l'économie, de la
donnée, de la et des plateformes,
c'est-à-dire interprétation,
recommandation et le euh donc il y a ce
modèle, il y a ce modèle de société, ce
modèle technico-économique qui est à
l'œuvre, qui regarde tous les individus
et qui ne cesse de s'intensifier, hein,
qui ne cesse de s'intensifier, qui ne
cesse de coller au comportement. Donc,
on peut discuter avec qui tu veux Sky,
mais là, c'est un fait objectif et moi
ce n'est pas une vision de la vie
premièrement qui m'enchante.
Est-ce que je peux te couper ?
Je t'en prie.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
On est au 21e siècle. On a un système
financier qui est en train de se alors
c'est un peu caricatural mais tu noteras
tu noteras de trois deux trois choses.
On a un système financier qui devient de
plus en plus instable qui crée de plus
en plus d'inégalités, un système fiscal
qui est en train de se gaufrer, une
dislocation géopolitique mondiale avec
une réagglomération à l'ancienne façon
guerre froide. On a des guerres en
Ukraine avec les Russes. On a eu des
guerres avec les Israéliens et les
Palestins.
Le désordre et la désorientation
prévale, ça c'est sûr.
Il y en a plein en terme de de société.
On a de plus en plus d'obésité, on a de
plus en plus de dépressif, on a de plus
en plus de consommation de calement, on
a de plus en plus d'embouteillage, on a
une maximisation de de tous les
problèmes que les sociétés occidentales,
une amplification,
une intensification.
Merci.
L'intelligence artificielle, ça va
peut-être nous aider. standardiser, je
sais, je te provoque, je fais exprès.
Standardiser un peu le comportement des
poulets, ça fait gagner du temps. Bah,
tu as pris au au vol ce que j'allais
dire, Bertrand. Exactement.
C'est le fait que la deuxième
conséquence, c'est d'engager une
hyperrationalisation
de la société dans tous les secteurs,
euh
une hyper optimisation
de de de la vie collective et ça a lieu
dans quantité de champ dans
l'administration principalement pas
principalement beaucoup dans le travail.
J'avais parlé je crois de des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle
qui sont à l'œuvre dans les entrepôts
Amazon. Ça fait 10 ans que je tourne en
bouc, je répète ce cas de figure dont
tout le monde se contrefiche quand même
hein. C'est-à-dire là, c'est totalement
c'est directement issu de de
des développements de des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle. Qui voit
quoi dans le tournant injonctif de la
technologie ? Mais les exemples sont de
plus en plus nombreux et là c'est un
stade extrême dont on se dont on se don
sur lequel on ne se penche pas et qui
voit quoi ? qui voit par exemple dans le
e-commerce que nous ne cessons
d'alimenter, hein, qui voit des
manufacturiers euh qui qui ont des
capteurs, que ça soit leur tablette, que
ça soit des capteurs et euh équipé de
d'oreillettes et audio et qui voient des
systèmes interpréter en temps réel leur
positionnement, leur localisation et
leur enjoindre, là c'est pas de
l'incitation, d'aller à tel endroit
rechercher tel article dans telle
palette pour la remettre à telle vitesse
dans telle palette.
réduisant des êtres à des robots de
chair de sang avant que même il ne soi
plus tard remplacé par des robots dotés
de qualité kinesthésiste.
Et cela est euh
cela offense la singularité, la dignité,
l'intégrité des êtres. Et quand on parle
de régulation sur lequel nous
reviendrons la régulation, et bien
personne ne s'en soucie. Donc
l'intelligence artificielle,
les principales conséquences, c'est
l'acé d'une histoire, du capitalisme, du
libéralisme, du technolibéralisme,
c'est-à-dire de coller à nos existences
de façon personnalisée en continu en vue
de de de nous inciter, nous encourager,
nous pousser, nous dire euh engager des
des transactions marchandes et c'est
d'organiser une société qui à terme
devrait être délivré de du moindre
défaut et procédant par le plus grand
gain et la moindre perte.
J'en profite pour poser une question
internet de Fox. Question pour l'invité.
Ce que l'on baptise IA, notamment en ce
qu'elle vise à remplacer le travail
humain, n'estce pas l'étape ultime du
capitalisme une forme d'ultime
révolution industrielle réussie où il
n'y aurait plus aucune contestation
possible.
Oui, on peut je serais pas aussi radical
en tout cas ça ne fait pas que remplacer
le travail humain hein. Pour l'instant,
ce n'est pas que ça. Il y a cette
perspective, on va reparler avec les
génératives. Il y a d'abord un
accompagnement, une un encadrement,
c'est-à-dire
un nouveau stade du management qui est à
l'œuvre, le management qui a qui est
indissociable du tournant une
radicalisation du management qui est
indissociable du tournant néolibéral qui
est à l'œuvre depuis les années 80,
hein. management, voulant dire
euh évaluation des personnes dans le cas
du travail, voulant dire euh orientation
des gestes plus ou moins formulé, plus
ou moins manifesté, voulant dire adosser
le travail à des programmes déterminés à
l'avance, voulant dire finalement
robotisation du geste du geste humain et
alignement de nos capacités
intellectuelles à des dictats
déterminés, défin fini par d'autres au
nom de supposés objectifs qui seraient
pour le bien de l'entreprise. Donc
l'humanité
pardon
ou de l'humanité.
Voilà. Et donc ces systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle dans leur
puissance d'expertise et d'orientation,
ça imprégné
toute tout le champ du management hein,
mais pas seulement tout le champ de la
société. C'est-à-dire que dans dans
l'administration, dans la justice, dans
l'hôpital,
dans euh on l'a dit dans le dans le dans
nos rapports à ce qu'est le ce qu'est le
commerce, il y a quelque chose comme
des voix qui nous parlent, comme une
vérité qui nous parle, une vérité qui
nous parle qui est supposée euh regarder
le bon chemin emprunté, hein, qui et le
fait que de plus en plus alors moi je
veux bien qu'on échange avec des
contradicteurs mais là c'est un fait que
de plus en plus
des systèmes
parlent à notre place c'est ça qui est à
l'ure avec l'intelligence artificielle
et des systèmes qui parlent à notre
place en vue des deux principales visés
que j'ai énoncé
et maintenant ce que nous voyons avec
l'avèement des images généritives c'est
non seulement des systèmes qui parlent à
notre place mais des systèmes qui
parlent en notre
Alors là, c'est comme si c'était une
dernière frontière qui était franchie
dans des systèmes qui régentent,
qui aussi se saisissent de nos facultés,
c'est-à-dire de nous déterminer
librement, d'agir individuellement comme
on le souhaite, relativement à un cadre
de de lois, de règlements qui sont
communs, relativement à des collectifs
de nous déterminer librement. ce que
nous avons vécu depuis une quarantaine
d'années et plus encore depuis une
dizaine d'années, c'est des systèmes qui
portent une idéologie qui aussi porte
une le postulat que euh l'automatisation
des affaires humaines, l'automatisation
de l'action humaine, c'est faire mieux
euh le organiser mieux le cours des
choses que si c'était les humains qui le
faisaient. C'est ça aussi le postulat
qu'il faut voir et c'est le c'est le
c'est le postulat est fondé sur le fait
que nous sommes profondément lacunair,
je l'avais dit ça en 2018 dans le gard
de notre entretien, mais que des
systèmes de plus en plus omniscients
savent mieux que nous-mêmes ce que nous
devons savent mieux que nous-mêmes ce
que nous devons faire.
Tu as de l'eau juste à ta gauche.
Merci. savent mieux que nous-mêmes ce
que nous devons faire et euh
et
ce moment-là qui ne cesse de
s'intensifier, c'est-à-dire des des
technologies qui parlent à notre place
mais qui aussi en faisant ça procède de
l' d'uneutom automatis
qu'il faut qu'on ait à l'esprit c'est
qui dit automatisation dit toujours
privatisation.
C'est-à-dire là où il y a automatis, il
y a génération de nouveaux modèles
économiques, nouveaux gissements de
profit avec le fait d'évacuer les
humains et le fait que de nouveaux
intermédiaires et de nouveaux
chantiers économiques se mettent en
place. Et maintenant, le moment que nous
vivons qui est
extrêmement troublant
euh dont je remarque qu'il a connu une
banalisation qu'il n'aurait pas dû
connaître, on va on va en parler, c'est
le fait que maintenant euh des systèmes
parlent en nom, parlent en notre nom,
réfléchissent en notre nom, ressentent
en notre nom.
Certainement pas.
Je te mets certainement pas.
Je te mets le cas de figure pendant que
tu bois un coup.
Certainement pas. On ne peut ressentir à
sa juste valeur ce qu'on ne peut pas
exprimer clairement.
Déjà, déjà, qu'est-ce que tu penses de
cette phrase là ?
Je veux bien la réentendre, s'il te
plaît.
On ne peut pas ressentir à sa juste
valeur ce que peut pas exprimer
finement.
Et la deuxième chose de qui n'a rien à
voir, c'est on voit une baisse
généralisée des cautions
intellectuelles. On voit une baisse
généralisé généralisée de la qualité
d'enseignement.
sans faire de généralité, on se retrouve
avec une masse de personnes
oppressé, sous sous pression, avec du
stress, qui a pas le temps de se
cultiver, qui a pas le temps de prendre
le temps de réfléchir, de cultiver son
jardin secret, d'avoir une amplitude de
vocabulaire lui permettant d'exprimer la
justesse de ses émotions.
L'intelligence artificielle, c'est un
peu une canne numérique sur une une
Peugeot 605. C'est que ça aide. Ah bah
c'est évident mais on peut pas déigner à
l'industrie numérique la silicone vallée
mais plus largement à l'économie du
numérique de savoir très bien jouer de
notre inclination fondamentale à la
paresse et à notre passion pour le
confort. Ça c'est mais ça c'est
un fait, ça complique les choses. Et
relativement à la phrase que j'ai plus
ou moins comprise, je suis désolé mais
je on peut je pourrais reformuler
autrement hein sans
je m'attends au pire tu es désolé là.
Non non non mais prolonger en tout cas
c'est qu'en tous les cas on ne peut on
ne pourrait exprimer très bien
clairement que ce qu'on ressent bien. Là
je parle de sens de corps. Pourquoi je
parle de corps ? Parce que si tu veux
bien maintenant je parle d'A générative
qui est un des enjeux majeurs de mon
livre à ceux qui ou à ceux à celles qui
connaissent pas générative ça veut dire
quoi ? Alors, générative,
c'est ce que j'ai ce qu'on a évoqué euh
en entame jusqu'à maintenant,
c'est euh le tournant
cognitif
organisationnel
des technologies numériques et de
l'intelligence artificielle. le dans son
premier grand moment d'extrême
sophistication, en gros celui qui est à
l'œuvre depuis le milieu la fin des
années 2000 qui a concouru à permettre
une organisation optimisée des affaires
humaines hein et de plus optimiser de
plus en plus optimisé. Ça c'est ce
moment que nous vivons depuis une
quinzaine d'années dont je redis qu'on
ne saisit pas suffisamment l'ampleur des
conséquences juridique politicaux
juridique social civilisationnel et
aussi la redéfinition de la posture
humaine de la figure humaine. C'estàd
quelle est la place de chacun d'entre
nous et de l'humanité et de la figure
humaine relativement à des systèmes qui
organisent prétendument toujours mieux
le cours de nos affaires en vue de des
deux finalités que que j'ai euh que j'ai
exposé maintenant avec les I génératifs.
Donc je vais expliquer de quoi il
s'agit. C'est un autre tournant. J'ai
presque envie de dire, c'est un tout à
l'heure je parlais d'autres
embranchements, c'est un autre
embranchement dans l'histoire de
l'intelligence artificielle comme si ça
ne suffisait pas cette ce moment-là que
nous vivons depuis une quinzaine
d'années qui nous démunit, qui qui
impose des schémas de façon extrêmement
profonde, qui banalise aussi des
modalités
qui s'imposent comme étant unique et
inéluctable.
la vitesse
la vitesse des développements
technologiques et le fait que là aussi
je l'avais dit que ce qui caractérise
les systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
c'est que ce ne sont pas des
technologies stables, ce sont des
technologies en développement sans cesse
croissant en sophistication sans cesse
croissante. Ça ne cesse de se développer
qui est un problème qui nous regarde
hein qui est un problème qui nous
regarde et qui nous complique les
choses. C'estàd ça ça va tellement vite
hein. et
euh ça va tellement vite, ça s'impose et
euh et ça complique la faç la le devoir
que nous avons à nous déterminant
librement et en conscience relativement
à ces phénomènes. Non, il y a des il y a
des intérêts, il y a des ingénieurs
inféodés à l'industrie numérique qui
nous disent "Ne vous inquiétez pas, tout
cela est formidable, ça va nous ouvrir
quantité d'horizon
bienvenue, mais il y a quelques
inconvénients, on va s'en occuper." Non,
non, non, non, non, non. Les choses sont
autrement graves que cela et à mon sens,
on ne le voit pas. Je je ne cesse de
l'analyser. Et là, ce que nous vivons
avec les intelligences artificielles
dites dite intelligence dite
artificielle
générative
générative non mais sur le thème
intelligence artificielle j'avais
critiqué le terme à l'époque
euh intelligence artificielle générative
c'est le tournant
intellectuel et créatif et ça c'est pas
rien des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle alors on va on va on va
donner des exemples concrets sur il a
génér
non plus le tournant qui continue le
tournant cognitif et organisationnel
rien que ça déjà ça dit beaucoup
tournant cognitif et organisationnel des
technologies daté doté de de cognition
hein de de compréhension des phénomènes
d'expertise je disais tout à l'heure et
organisationnel maintenant c'est le
tournant intellectuel hein et créatif
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans plus
que jamais dans le tournant
anthropomorphique de la technologie
quand je parle de de grav gravité de
moment que nous vivons. C'est-à-dire que
ce qui est à l'œuvre depuis la
cybernétique, mais beaucoup plus encore
depuis une quinzaine d'années, c'est que
la façon dont on conçoit les
technologies du dans le monde de
l'intelligence de d'intelligence
artificielle, dans les laboratoires, la
façon dont on les conçoit, mais pas
seulement la façon dont on les conçoit,
les fonctionnalités qu'on veut leur
donner, c'est s'inspirer prétendument du
cerveau humain, hein, de façon assez
grossière avec toute une tout un langage
abusif qui parle de réseau de neurones,
de logique d'apprentissage machine,
machine learning en anglais et cetera,
comme si les machines n'étaient pas loin
d'un état qui est quasiment identique
aux autres, ce qui est totalement faux
parce que ça supposerait que ces
systèmes pourraient comme naturellement
se substituer à nos corps, à nos esprits
et à nos facultés cognitives et
intellectuelles. Donc
prendre conscience. Donc alors ce
tournant anthropomorphique,
il est à l'œuvre puissamment dans les
laboratoires
mais aussi comme modèle. Comme modèle
parce que le modèle, il remonte à la
cybernétique. Ça aussi il faut voir d'où
nous venons. C'est pour ça que je fais
toujours une généalogie de de notre
histoire quand je quand que quand je me
confronte à certains enjeux. Le modèle
qui est à l'œuvre, c'est le cerveau
humain. C'est ça, hein. C'est l'idée de
vouloir prétendument
dupliquer via des technologie toujours
plus sophistiqué et puissante ce qui
nous avec notre corps, avec notre
sensibilité nous caractérise
en en premier enfin dans dans toute
notre grandeur et dans toute notre dans
notre humanité, dans tout notre génie.
C'est l'idée
notre déchéance.
Non, pas d'échéance. Non non dans tout
dans tout notre génie qui
malheureusement ne cesse d'être d'être
d'être non considéré, je veux dire
justement notamment par des systèmes
dont on nous dit non seulement ils sont
inspirés prétendument inspirés de notre
cerveau, mais c'est plus encore que
cela. C'est l'idée en vue de répondre à
des tâches toujours plus nombreuses,
cognitives, organisationnel jusqu'à
comment quel chemin prendre plutôt que
tel autre, quelle
molécule de bien-être prendre plutôt que
tel autre, jusqu'à comment nous
organiser dans les collectifs de
travail, jusqu'à comment
prendre tel article dans telle palette
et les déposer à telle vitesse. Bref,
cette ces systèmes qui savent
prétendument dans tous les cas, on leur
octroit cette fonction et cette position
mieux que nous. Ce qui est supposé nous
convenir donc c'est quand je parle de
conséquences politico juridiques, social
et civilisationnel, il faut prendre la
mesure de cela. Mais c'est pas se pas
ça. C'est le fait que euh c'est ce que
je disais là, c'est que avec l'idée que
d'une perfection, parce que l'horizon
c'est la perfection, l'horizon c'est le
zéro défaut, c'est l'hygiénisme et que
cette automatisation n'en doutons pas,
n'en doutez pas. Et bien sûr qu'il faut
en douter plus que jamais, il faudrait
pas qu'en douter, faudrait s'interposer.
Ces systèmes vont mieux faire que nous
tous dans tous les champs de la vie. ce
que nous savons, ce que nous faisons,
n'est-ce pas ? Ce que tu venais de dire,
très très mal dans le chaos, dans le
désordre, mais nous ne devons pas nous
alarmer bientôt des systèmes de la
prétendue supériorité de nous-même.
C'est un autre nom qu'on pourrait
donner.
Une religion
euh euh pardon,
une religion,
pas une religion, le
un sauveur, un messie. Je j'utiliserai
pas ces termes. Je préfère évoquer la
notion de technologie de la prétendue
supériorité de nous-même. Si qui dit
prétendu supériorité de nous-même, ça
veut dire tu n'as pas droit à la parole.
C'est c'est vers ça. C'est comme ça
qu'il faut nous organiser.
C'est vachement bien ça.
C'est c'est tellement bien que c'est en
vue des deux des deux perspectives dont
j'ai parlé. Et maintenant, c'est le
tournant, on l'a dit, intellectuel.
C'est-à-dire que c'est plus seulement
interpréter les situations,
évaluer ce qu'il se passe, évaluer les
personnes, évaluer les situations,
évaluer les modes d'organisation en
commun et prendre des décisions en
fonction de notre autonomie de jugement,
de notre liberté, de nos envies, de nos
aspirations, mais aussi de nos
principes. C'est plus seulement ça.
Maintenant, c'est ce qui nous
caractérise le plus en propre, nos
facultés les plus fondamentales qui sont
appelées à être assuré, prise en charge
par des systèmes. Quand je dis nos
facultés les plus fondamentales, c'est
au premier chef celle de produire du
langage, ce que nous faisons là, hein,
c'està-dire de parler, de parler en
première personne.
et
tu m'as demandé de revenir d'expliquer,
de préciser ce à quoi nous avons affaire
avec l'intelligence artificielle.
Alors, il y a une date, c'est le 30
novembre 2022.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le 30 novembre
2022 ? C'est la mise en ligne publique à
l'échelle du globe de la version 3 de
Chat GPT ou 3,5, je me souviens plus. 3,
hein, bon, peu importe. Et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ? Et ce qui s'est passé,
c'est que ça a été une sidération
des foules. La plupart des personnes des
commentaires disait que c'était
bluffant, des systèmes qui sur
instruction produisaient du langage.
Mais que il fallait, c'était c'était la
majorité des commentaires, tu dois t'en
souvenir, mais qu'il fallait qu'il y ait
encore nombre de développement de
sophistication pour que ça s'apparente à
un langage semblable nôtre. un langage
humain. Alors, c'est là qu'elle notre
grande illusion et c'est là que je
pointe notre erreur d'appréciation, de
jugement et la gravité de ce qui se
passe. Je peux m'expliquer Sky ?
Notre illusion serait de croire que
c'est un langage humain. Pour quelle
raison ? Et ça dès janvier
2023, je m'en suis expliqué dans une
tribune qui a été traduite dans tribune
qui est paru dans le monde qui
s'appelait Chatbt, l'illusion d'un
langage naturel et qui a été publié dans
je sais pas 6 se pays en Allemagne,
aux États-Unis, en Espagne, bon bref, en
Italie, en Hollande.
Et j'expliquais quoi ? J'analysais quoi
? J'analysais le fait que il fallait
voir avant de nous enthousiasmer quels
sont les ressorts de ces technologies de
ces systèmes, comment ils fonctionne
pour saisir la portée de ce qui se joue,
la gravité de ce qui se joue.
En train de casser mes rêves là. Je
pensais qu'il y avait des petits nains
dans mon ordinateur qui écrivaient.
Il y a des petits nains.
Il y a des petits nains mais
des nains
des nains pourris par la nécrose qui
sont nécrosés qui sont profondément
autour de autour des calu de la mort. Je
vais m'expliquer.
Ah oui, je vais m'expliquer.
C'est quoi ? C'est des le prochain
des le prochars
pas.
C'est c'est une sorte de nain un peu
moins beau que les nôtres. dont je
connais pas. Alors, comment fonctionnent
ces systèmes ? Ça, c'est sur ça qu'on
aurait dû se pencher. D'abord, ces
systèmes cherchent en tous les cas, on
cherche à la faire ingurgiter le plus
grand nombre de corpus dans une
dimension totalisante. Tu te souviens
qu'à l'époque, on avait dit, ils avaient
un gurgité un gurgité, il y a déjà
quelque chose une volonté totalisante
dans ce projet. Ils ont stocké
ils ont ils ont stocké ils ont récolté
hein. Récolté stocké. à l'époque,
c'était jusqu'en 2021 ce qu'il y avait
sur internet et puis sur d'autres bases
de données. Ils ont collecté, tu as bien
raison de dire, ingurgité hein, cherché
ingurgité, collecté et stocké. et des
systèmes les ont soumis à des euh
traitements statistiques, à des
équations mathématique
euh en vue de dégager et d'affiner des
règles formelles du langage, ce qu'on
appelle les large language model, des
grands modèles de langage formalisés qui
puissent être intégrés par les systèmes,
qui apprennent de plus en plus de règles
et qui seraient à même de toujours
composer de façon
prétendument cohérente
les corpus.
Mais ce qu'on n' pas vu, la grande
affaire de cela, c'est que quand on
donne une instruction
euh ça produit euh par exemple, on dit
je comme on venait sur WhatsApp ou sur
certaines plateformes, on dit je viens
te voir et puis ça rajoute le système
dit ce soir parce que la plus grande
probabilité c'est que c'est ce soir.
Tout nu c'est non. Comment c'est moins
probable à moins que tu ai eu des
habitudes de dire d'écrire souvent et
alors c'est intégré par le système.
C'est ça qu'on appelle le machine
learning mais en réalité c'est
l'intégration statistique de certains
comportements et de certains usages.
Chantill Chantill aussi ça marche.
Voilà et de d'équation mathématique.
Mais ce ce langage, ce pseudo langage
produit des termes à l'intérieur et
c'est cela le le le point capital sur
lequel je voudrais attirer votre
attention
qui se produit du langage à l'intérieur
d'une dimension
probabiliste. Probabiliste, c'est-à-dire
la plus grande occur chance possible que
ça soit telle occurrence plutôt que
telle autre. Ça c'est le schéma formel,
le schéma technologique qui est à
l'œuvre qui s'apparenterait donc à un
langage humain semble-t-il et c'est le
cas à première vue. Or ça fonctionne à
l'opposé de notre usage du langage à
l'opposé absolu qui jamais nous chacun
de nous n'entretenons un rapport
totalisant au leg au leg commun. la
langue, les corpus, les règles, les lois
du langage, mais où il y a de
l'apprentissage, un lien subjectif,
singulier que nous entretenons à euh à
la à la langue, aux langues, aux règles.
Et quoi ? qui fait que chacun a une
histoire particulière
au langage, hein, la une histoire qui
est de l'ordre de l'imagination, de la
culture,
de de la capacité de de se réapproprier
les choses, de de singulariser, de se
singulariser par la langue, ce qu'on
appelle parler en première personne
couper
et qui fait je termine juste sur le plus
important et qui fait aussi et qui
procède aussi du fait que le mot que je
vais dire là maintenant, mon cher Sky
Le mot que je vais dire là maintenant,
il s'inscrit pas à l'intérieur d'une
dimension probabiliste, mais il
s'inscrit à l'intérieur d'une dimension
indéterministe. Et c'est là le distingo
fondamental, c'est-à-dire la dimension
indéterministe, c'est le cœur, c'est le
levier de la liberté humaine et de la
créativité humaine. C'est-à-dire que le
mot que je vais dire là, une seconde
avant, je ne sais pas que je vais le
dire. Et pourtant, la façon dont je
parle là, c'est un lien continu entre
l'ensemble commun, le leg commun, le leg
historique commun, la culture, le
langage, euh le le leg présent, les
corpus en cours, ma culture et le fait
que moi dans ma liberté humaine, je
parle au moment présent dans une liberté
absolue et d'une façon absolument
singulière. C'est pour cela que je dis
que nous nous trompons en croyant qu'il
s'agit d'un langage s'apparent à un
langage humain. C'est un pseudo langage.
C'est une langue morte, nécrosée,
industrialisée, mathématisée,
euh standardisé.
Et que s'est pass que s'est-il passé ?
Que s'est-il passé au mois de novembre,
au mois de janvier ? Que s'est-il passé
? C'est que des foules ont dit "Mais
c'est cool chat GPT. C'est cool.
C'est-à-dire sans voir les conséquences
civilisationnelles de voir des
compagnies privées au nom de leur seul
profit développer des systèmes qui sont
appelés à nous déprendre de notre
faculté la plus fondamentale, celle de
parler en première personne, celle de
parler, d'échanger, de
d'exprimer notre liberté via le langage.
Et moi, je comprends cela. Comment je
prends je comprends cela ? par le fait
que l'utilitarisme qui est tellement à
l'œuvre dans nos sociétés depuis plus
d'un siècle, utilitarisme voulant dire
selon les notions de Jeremy Bantam,
philosophe anglais que la société doit
tout maximiser, hein, c'est-à-dire
éviter le moindre la moindre perte et
procéder par le plus grand profit dans
dans l'organisation sociale des choses.
Et ça c'est tellement
institutionnalisé,
banalisé, développé et devenu la norme
dominante de nos sociétés que ça en est
arrivé à infiltrer nos cerveils.
C'est-à-dire sans nous soucier de
l'étendue des conséquences dont je vais
parler hein. Les personnes, en tous les
cas des foules de personnes, on dit
c'est utile, c'est hyper cool, ça me
facilite la tâche. Mais sans voir quoi ?
sans voir que nous organisons,
en gros, on peut dire les choses par une
formule qui va être un peu punchy,
que l'utilité, notre inclination
instituée aujourd'hui pour
l'utilitarisme
et le cheval de 3 du renoncement à
nous-mêmes, du renoncement à nos
facultés les plus fondamentales. Parce
que voyons-nous deux choses, mon cher
Sky, voyons-nous deux choses.
Voyons-nous d'abord le fait que ce
régime de langage, si nous n'y prenons
garde, va être de plus en plus
important. il va être de plus en il est
appelé à terme à devenir majoritaire,
c'est-à-dire un langage probabiliste,
nécrosé, pseudo langage va de plus en
plus être celui qui est à l'œuvre entre
dans dans notre paysage symbolique et
dans nos relations interpersonnelles.
C'est-à-dire que l'impersonnalisation de
la société qui est à l'œuvre depuis le
tournant néolibéral particulièrement
mais déjà depuis bien plus longtemps, le
fait que des systèmes parlent à notre
place, là il y a un langage impersonnel
nécrousé au nom de notre utilité qu'on
va se dire "Mais c'est cool qu'on va
utiliser qui va qui va qui va on est
quoi ? On est en octobre 2023, je vous
donne rendez-vous 2025 2026 pour voir le
le régime de langage qui va se prise
qui va qui va se g mais je on va prendre
une date pour autre chose aussi pour nos
enfants en
vacances mais mais aussi pour nos
enfants
avant que tu
je termine juste sur sur nos enfants
d'accord
voiton voit-on
d'ici quelques années nos enfants, nos
petits enfants nous dirent
mais pourquoi vais-je à l'école
Pourquoi pourquoi vais-je à l'école si
sur simple instruction de ma part des
systèmes vont pouvoir me dessiner un
mouton, me pouvoir produire des textes,
pouvoir créer
produire une dissertation, pouvoir
m'écrire
cr une lettre de de rupture ou d'amour ?
On m'a dit, c'est le titre de l'article
de l'entretien qui est paru dans le
Figaro hier et des gens ont dit "Mais on
n'écrit plus de lettre d'amour." Bah
c'est dommage. Écris-moi une lettre
d'amour. Fait
des SMS de love.
Euh
là, j'envoie ma question tout je te
Oui.
Quand on voit des SMS de love avec des
mots de vocabulaire qui se réduisent
comme pot de chagrin, un champ lexical,
un champ lexical qui se flétrit ou qui
perd toute cohérence. Alors, je vais je
vais prendre les les
les divagations du petit Robert, que la
langue s'enrichit chaque année et ainsi
de suite, sauf que la maîtrise du
vocabulaire,
c'est très juste que tu dis. C'est c'est
en train de se
c'est très juste. C'est avéré, c'est
documenté
et donc et donc on se
donc c'est cool. On a des systèmes qui
vont très bien écrire. C'est ça. Je je
te vois venir. Ben je te vois venir mais
j'ai pensé j'ai pensé à ça.
Donc tu te retrouves avec une grande
partie de la population
qui a pas le temps, qui est sous
pression, qui a des problèmes de boulot,
qui a des problèmes de gamin, qui a des
problèmes de violence, qui a des
problèmes de transport en commun, qui a
des problèmes d'inflation et je pourrais
égrainer la liste encore et encore
encore. a pas le temps de prendre du
temps pour se muscler le cerveau pour
que les gamins ne s'abrutissent pas avec
ce qu'on appelle la nouvelle guerre
cognitive avec TikTok ces conneries.
On se retrouve avec une population et
pardonne-moi le mot de plus en plus très
panée. Hm
hm.
Et donc la canne la canne numérique de
l'intelligence artificielle dans un
système hyper capitalisé hyper
capitaliste qui fonctionne sur une
fonction exponentielle
c'est l'équivalent un peu du doliprane
pour très pané.
Donc le le del ce que fait le delran
Scarry, tu sais ce que fait le deliprade
? C'està dire qu'il ne fait que penser
la douleur mais il s'attaque pas à la
cause hein. C'est le propre du
doliprade. Donc ce que tu dis ça ne fait
qu'entériner les choses ça c'estàdire
très super cool
et on les met sous perfusion de
subvention jusqu'à les pades et on est
tranquille. Bon alors on va je te
propose de voir Laurent Alexandre.
Bon je te propose de voir légèrement
voir très autrement les choses.
Est-ce que tu peux concevoir ça ? Je
non parce que tu es un puriste.
Non c'est pas que je suis un puriste.
C'est qu' n'est
Ça remonte à quand ta dernière lettre
d'amour que tu as écrite avec ta que tu
as écrit avec ta petite main ? 4 5 ans,
je me souviens très bien. Euh et j'ai eu
du mal à écrire parce qu'on on s'espère
hein, on est dans les mails, on est dans
les SMS hein, ne m'oublie pas, je pense
à toi. Voilà, l'être d'amour c'est un ça
c'est parce que tu es vieux ça.
La lettre d'amour, c'est aussi
et c'est surtout de la mobilisation et
de l'implication pour l'autre hein et
aussi la mobilisation de ses propres
facultés, de son envie de de donner
peut-être pas le meilleur mais une belle
part de soi-même à autrui. À autrui. Ça
c'est parce que tu n'es pas un pervers
manipulateur.
Bon, on va pas entrer dans ces
catégories. En tous les cas euh pourquoi
tu tu m'as dit je suis impuriste ? Je
suis pas un puriste. En tous les cas, je
ne dirai pas les choses comme ça.
Un puriste.
Non mais Bertrand, laisse-moi là s'il te
plaît développer.
Je suis je moi il y a quand je on dit
technocritique, philosophe critique, il
faut aller plus loin que ça. Moi mes
analyses s'adosent à des critères très
clairs. Tu parlais d'échange tout à
l'heure avec Laurent Alexandre, si tu
veux. Moi, je crois que ça sert pas à
grand-chose mais en tous les cas, les
critères ne seraient pas les mêmes. Moi,
j'ai des critères qui sont très
Ça sert. Détrompe-toi.
Bon. Peu importe, c'est pas c'est pas
l'enjeu du jour, on va se dire hein.
Moi, j'ai des critères. J'ai des
critères. C'est la la sauvegarde, la
préservation intangible. intangible,
mais aussi pas que la sauvegarde d'une
d'une dimension euh défensive, mais
aussi la célébration
de nos principes les plus fondamentaux,
de nos valeurs les plus fondamentales.
le respect et la célébration de la
dignité, de l'intégrité humaine, des
rapports charnels entre les êtres, de la
mise en place de modalités d'existence
au commun qui soient les plus
équitables, qui ne laissent personne et
la célébration du sensible et la
célébration de du génie qui est logé en
chacun d'entre nous et de nos capacités
intellectuelles
en théoriquement infini. La vocal,
c'est ça. Alors, laisse-moi développer,
s'il te plaît. Laisse-moi développer sur
cela.
Sky, je te demande de de me laisser
développer parce que là, je touche le
nerf de de ce qui est à l'œuvre dans ce
livre qui m'a fait suer. J'ai l'air
fatigué. Tu m'as dit parce que je
travaille beaucoup
comment
tu bosses beaucoup.
Je bosse beaucoup. Je reviens d'une
tournée de conférence en Amérique du Sud
dans beaucoup de pays d'Europe.
Je t' voilà de avec les décalages
horaires. Bref, donc
s'il te plaît, laisse-moi poursuivre sur
sur ce point-là que nous évoquons là.
Tu me dis, j'ai bien compris ton ironie
hein, personne se trompe que c'est en
toute amitié et dans une amicale ironie
et une chaleureuse ironie que tu énonces
là.
Moi, je ne pourrais jamais entériner et
dire qu'il y a des personnes, des
foules, des humains en difficulté et en
désérance et donc des systèmes vont être
des béquis qui vont en gros entretenir
cela et organiser un renoncement de
nous-même. Ça d'un point de vue humain,
d'un point de vue philosophique, d'un
point de vue de valeur, je ne peux pas
accepter cela. D'ailleurs, tu vois, d'un
coup, je viens de m'énerver. Alors,
quand je m'énerve, c'est bon signe en
général. C'est-à-dire que c'est c'est
moi qui suis mobilisé dans dans les
valeurs qui m'animent et dans le fait
que je suis avec mes analyses, je
contredis des discours et je cherche à
ou en tous les cas à défaire des
représentations qu'on se fait des
phénomènes parfois trop rapides parce
que les gens n'ont pas le temps
d'analyser, de voir ce qui se joue et
aussi qu'il y a des discours qui
recouvrent les phénomènes parce que ce à
quoi à quoi avons-nous à faire ? Nous
avons à faire. Je suis pas prophète
mais
je peux décrire ce que vont être les
prochaines années. Interview 2018, tu as
quand même mis.
Bon, il se trouve que je me suis pas
beaucoup trompé. On me le dit de plus en
plus he quand j'écris surveillance
globale en 2009, la siliconisation du
monde en 2016.
Bon, je me suis pas beaucoup trompé,
n'est-ce pas ? Même l'histoire des
trottinettes en 2019, il veut pas de
trottinette et cetera. J'ai dit non, il
faut des règles. Tribune dans l'IB, il
faut des règles faire des
infrastructures publiques dédiées, ça
coûte une fortune. Ou alors on fait pas
ça et on interdit plus récent parce que
c'est un c'est un chaos absolu dans les
rues. Ouais. Même sur un détail de
trottinette, franchement, j'avais vu les
juste parce que il y avait une doxa
l'économie de la donnée des des
plateformes en 2019 c'était la mobilité
tout c'est écologique, tu sais toute
cette nev langue là, toute cette nove
langue. Donc je suis pas un prophète
mais je vois quand même quand même ce
que je ce que j'ai dit dans la fin de
l'introduction. de mon bouquin, la vie
spectrale. La fin d'introduction, il y a
un mini chapitre, un paragraphe pardon
qui s'intitule le présent qui vient. Je
dis qu'il faut pas être futurologue.
C'est du c'est c'est du c'est ça n'a
aucun sens. Mais que moi je je pense qu'
qu'il nous revient de saisir quantité de
signes présents et de signes faibles qui
pour de multiples raisons euh sont
supposés se développer, se consolider et
s'imposer sans que nous puissions nous
déterminer parce qu'il y a des forces
puissantes qui qui l'imposent. en
l'occurrence l'industrie numérique et
toute une doxa et tout un environnement
idéologique qui l'impose. Donc je parle
de du présent qui vient, je théorise.
Michel Fouco disait le philosophe doit
être un diagnosticien. Ce que je fais
là, je me reconnais totalement dans
cette posture du philosophe. Ce que je
fais depuis une quinzaine d'années,
diagnostiquer les choses sans a priori
bien mal, ça ne m'intéresse pas. À quoi
avons-nous à faire ? Et les mettre dans
une posture critique à la mesure des
principes que je viens de dénoncer. Mais
je pense pour ma part de ce quand Fouo
disait il faut être un diagnosticien du
présent, le philosophe c'est son rôle en
tout cas pour celui qui se confronte au
présent philosophe de je sais pas de de
Blaise Pascal ou d'Emmanuel Kant, il est
dans l'histoire de la philosophie c'est
autre chose. Moi, je crois que dans
notre environnement contemporain, il ne
suffit pas d'être un philosophe
diagnosti du du temps présent, il le
faut, mais du du présent imminent, du
présent qui vient. Pourquoi ? parce que
en pouvant signaler en signalant des
trajectoires qui que l'on sent que l'on
voit d'un point de vue théorique c'est
un paris que je me fais c'est un paris
théorique mais un paris qui qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre que je pourrais
avoir dans dans le cadre de relation
établie avec le lecteur mais aussi dans
le cadre de la culture c'estàdire quel
est le rôle d'un livre aujourd'hui en
tout cas un livre philosophique qui
analyse ces enjeux-là c'est que ça
puisse ce présent qui vient ce présent
imminent nous donner
des armes, ce qui nous a tant manqué
depuis une quinzaine d'années, à même de
pouvoir agir, intervenir et j'en
reparlerai tout à l'heure si tu veux
bien
au moment même et peut-être un peu avant
que que le moment le grand moment où ça
va s'institutionnaliser
et ou quoi il sera trop tard et on dira
il faut un peu de régulation, un peu de
pensement et là ce qu'il vient ce qui
vient c'est pour ça que je disais je
suis pas prophète mais ce que je sent
très fort et j'ai senti quand même pas
mal de choses, n'est-ce pas, depuis une
quinzaine d'années ce que je ce qui ce
qui vient là, il vient beaucoup de
choses mais relativement aux
technologies numériques et à
l'intelligence artificielle et les I
génératives, je le redis bien
générative, le tournant intellectuel et
créatif des fonctionnalités des missions
qui sont d'évolu au système
d'intelligence artificielle. Ce qui
vient, c'est les promptes, c'est le
promptisme généralisé. C'est ça les 20
prochaines années, c'est le promptisme
généralisé. Alors les promptes, mais ça
c'est fond c'est capital. C'est à quoi
avons-nous à faire hein ? Gens qui
disent il y a génératif, c'est hyper
cool, c'est génial, Macron veut faire un
double de Pena, mais à quoi avons-nous à
faire ? Les promptes ? Les promptes,
c'est ça, tu vois, c'est Avachi sur le
canapé. Là, c'est un fauteuil, c'est pas
le canapé. Avachi donner des
instructions sur simple instruction
et euh pour des tâches qui jusqu'à
récemment et depuis la nuit des temps
mobiliser
nos facultés intellectuelles et
créatives, donner des instructions à des
systèmes pour qu'il le produisent.
C'est-à-dire produis-moi tel texte,
produis-moi telle image, produis-moi
telle musique. C'est-à-dire tout ce qui
relevait, tout ce qui euh procéder de la
mobilisation de nos facultés cognitives,
de notre culture, de nos capacités
intellectuelles, de nos capacités
créatives. Bref, je dis cette belle
expression du génie qui est logé en
chacun d'entre nous sur simple
instruction, c'est-à-dire le fait de de
donner d'être que qu'un donneur d'ordre
à des systèmes pour
me pas produire, développer, créer ce
qui nous revient fondamentalement en
propre. C'est ça le promptit.
C'est-à-dire dessine-moi ma maison,
dessine-moi
la la femme, la personne, l'homme, je ne
sais pas qui est supposé le mieux me
convenir. Fais-moi un texte, fais-moi ma
thèse. Bref, c'est l'idée de
d'aligner
des systèmes dotés de nos facultés les
plus fondamentales à notre propre vie, à
nos propres vues, on peut dire aussi vie
en temps réel avec une extrême facilité
et qui organise mais qui organise le
renoncement, l'oubli à terme, non
seulement le ce régime généralisé,
l'oubli de l'autonomie,
non à non pas à l'autonomie.
L'autonomie, c'est les systèmes qui
parlent à notre place. Ça c'est les
l'autonomie de jugement, c'est les les
IAS cognitives et organisationneles. Là,
c'est un renoncement à la flamme.
À la flamme. Nous sommes dans la flamme
là ensemble et même avec ceux qui qui
nous voient ce soir, on partage, on est
dans quelque chose qui qui est le
produit de nos intelligences, de nos
compréhensions, des systèmes à terme.
Tout ce qui je le redis,
c'est pas trop tard.
Alors alors avant de voir ce qui est
trop tard,
est-ce que des gens que tu croises dans
la rue qui ont plus la flamme dans les
yeux, il y en a beaucoup.
Alors mais mais là tu entérines encore.
Moi je ne veux pas enteriner. Je vais
t'expliquer pour jusque à quelle
je fais exprès.
Oui mais à quelle mesure je ne veux pas
enteriner. Mais le fait est je ne suis
pas allé au bout et après je vais parler
de l'image de il y a générative avec le
langage. Là je vais parler d'une d'une
chose de d'une au moins aussi extrême
gravité et portée.
C'est le fait que ça ne va pas seulement
parler en notre nom. Rendez compte ce
que ça veut dire dans notre civilisation
en 2023. des systèmes qui parlent en
notre nom qui vont nous défaire de notre
inclination naturelle mais à notre
devoir à notre responsabilité de parler
en première personne. Je le répète,
parler en première personne c'est le
vecteur premier, le levier premier de
l'expression de la liberté humaine en
société, c'est-à-dire dans la
singularité, dans la pluralité, dans la
contradiction et le fait de mener des
accords parce que ne nous ne nous
voilons pas la face. euh les systèmes
qui aspirent à du zéro défaut et à une
société hyper optimisée les les les IA
organisationnel. Là est l'idée qui est à
l'œuvre qu'on disait c'est bluffant mais
c'est pas encore un langage qui est
exactement humain mais c'est pas ça qui
est à l'œuvre. C'est l'idée c'est l'idée
de euh
d'une d'un langage pur. La pureté mais
la pureté quasi allez je n'utilise
jamais cet mais franchement on n'est pas
loin de ça la pureté quasi
je vais dire presqueenne ouéienne dans
ce qu'elle a de pire
je vais pas dire fascisante je n'aime
pas ces terme mais la pureté de le
langage parfait
ce que le ce qui nous caractérise c'est
que nous n'avons pas de personne ne
cherche à avoir un langage parfait mais
un langage singulier un langage
subjectif
Donc à côté de ça, la deuxième
dimension, c'est qu'ils vont non
seulement parler
à notre en notre nom, mais ils vont
aussi constamment nous parler. Alors, je
m'explique parce que sur un simple
instruction de notre part, on va leur
dire "Fais-moi, dis-moi ma recette de
cuisine. Fais-moi, moi qui suis à San
Francisco, ce jour, je viens d'atterrir,
je connais pas mon programme du jour.
Fais-moi mon programme euh fais-moi mon
programme du jour ou de ou d'aménagement
de ma maison le plus approprié, hein.
Les les exemples sont infinis
et c'est un langage
personnalisé. Et ça c'est déjà à l'œuvre
avec les moteurs de recherche respectifs
de Microsoft et de Google Bing ou Bard,
c'est-à-dire qui vont
sur simple instruction de notre part
produire du texte en vue d'orienter
l'action humaine, de déterminer nos
comportements, ce que j'ai appelé
l'orientation algorithmique de la vie,
mais là de façon plus précise par des
mots relativement à des instructions,
c'est-à-dire relativement à notre
demande même. pas des systèmes qui nous
disent faites c faites ça parfois on
sait même pas d'où ça vient non c'est
relativement à des instructions et qui
fait que qui fait quoi et ben qui fait
qu'on va toujours plus s'adosser
à des compagnies privées pour organiser
le cours de nos existences et qui
organise mais ça il faut le voir et ce
que j'analyse dans mon livre la vie
spectrale les fantômes et qui va
organiser
la le phénomène le plus continu, le plus
profond, le plus privé et collectif dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité, le plus
grand phénomène d'alignation mais
insensible, invisible,
naturalisé, c'est-à-dire le fait
d'adosser continuellement les existences
à des systèmes qui ne cherchent qu'à
générer des immenses profits
en nous disant le vrai ou en offrant des
systèmes qui organisent un renoncement à
nous-même. Et que voyons-nous à cela ?
On voit des personnes qui disent
"Sécoule". Mais oui, mais
la conscience peut-être qu'il nous
manque de la conscience,
de la maturité
et pas seulement. Il nous manque une
chose capitale que je tout ça je le
théorise dans mon livre très simplement,
très clairement.
Il nous manque le présent qui vient.
C'est-à-dire, on n'est que dans des
logiques court termistes. Personne ne va
plus ne voit plus loin. Quand je dis
personne, c'est des groupements, des
intérêts, des gouvernements, des
individus au-delà de son de de midi à sa
porte et euh euh jamais jamais dans un
délai un peu plus long qu'un qu'un
présent immédiat sans jamais saisir les
conséquences civilisationnelles. Et les
conséquences civilisationnelles, c'est
voilà ce ce langage impersonnalisé
qui qui aspire à quelque chose de de
pur.
qui est euh qui est automatisé, qui est
qui va nous organiser le renoncement à
nous-même. Et cela et cela
est à l'œuvre ce promptisme généralisé.
J'ai failli l'appeler mais on me dit on
s'est dit avec mon éditrice que c'était
un peu compliqué la vie prompte. Le
livre, j'ai failli l'appeler la vie
prompte. c'est les promptes, hein. Mais
les promptes, c'est pas seulement le
langage. Et là, ce que nous vivons
actuellement avec les les événements en
proche Orient,
le promptisme, c'est aussi ça c'est
d'une gravité extrême dont nous dont
nous commençons peut-être à saisir les
possibles conséquences, c'est le fait
que sur simple instruction de notre part
à vitesse en temps réel, des systèmes
vont pouvoir produire des générer
produire des images qui correspondent à
notre au moindre à nos moindres
souhaits.
ou à nos moindres lubis
ou à la moindre propagande. Alors
justement, la société n'est pas déjà
suffisamment atomisée, n'est déjà pas
suffisamment gangrainée par les fake
news, les ranqueurs, les haines qui
s'expriment, le complotisme, le fait que
chacun ne voit plus que la vérité au
prisme de ses propres difficultés, ses
propres souffrances, son ses sentiments,
mais à l'échelle de de la société pour
chacun d'avoir été laisé, que cela ce
moment devrait terminé, que maintenant
c'est le moment de du grand règlement de
compte avec un ordre des choses qui est
dans les réseaux sociaux. Donc ce que
j'ai analysé dans l'air de l'individu
tiran, c'est ce phénomène de
psychiatrisation sans cesse croissant de
la société qui a été favorisé par un
contexte historique et par l'usage de
des technologies numériques et notamment
des réseaux dissociaux que j'utilise
jamais ce terme et ce que j'appelle les
technologies de l'expressivité.
Euh ça ne suffit pas mon cher Sky, ça ne
suffit pas hein. Et donc maintenant on
va pouvoir sur simple instruction de
notre part dire euh d'Ali ou Mourné ou
d'autres euh
explique parce que sur la création
d'imagnée vas-y.
Alors c'est le même système c'est-à-dire
des systèmes qui analysent toujours des
corpus passés. C'est toujours l'idée
d'être lié au passé d'une façon, allez,
on va le dire, de façon un peu élégante
et précise et de façon névrotique au
passé, c'est-à-dire des des systèmes qui
ingurgitent quantité de choses
existantes et qui euh qu'il y a des
systèmes générateurs d'images, de
textes, toujours avec le système que
j'ai évoqué, hein, de
musique.
Comment de musique ? on va on va on doit
en parler hein et euh qui fait que c'est
à l'intérie en en ingurgitant, en
analysant, créant des modèles formels de
composition iconique, de composition
d'images, aussi bien d'images fixes que
d'images animées, de vidéos, et bien en
s'inspirant s'inspirant
en se modélisant, on va dire que sur des
images passées que les instructions
qu'on fait vont produire encore des
images nécrosées qui puent la mort en
réalité. Mais ça c'est OK, j'ai envie de
dire OK, il y aurait il y aurait tant de
choses à dire sur cela, mais il y a le
fait que sur simple instruction, mais en
une seconde, je vais pouvoir dire
"Fais-moi une image, une photo
générée dont on va de moins en moins
voir qu'elle est générée de de mon
voisin avec lequel j'ai un différent par
exemple qui frappe ma voisine dans
l'escalier et je le poste hein." et tout
est à l'avenant. Ça peut être des gamins
avec leurs professeurs, ça peut être
dans dans tout le champ de la société.
Euh le fait que euh en une seconde à
notre
euh aligné à nos propres vues, à nos
propres lubis, à nos propres
ressentiments, à nos propres haines, on
va pouvoir non seulement générer des
images qui vont avoir de plus en plus
une allure de réalité, de vérité,
d'exactitude
et qui vont de surcroix de plus en plus
comme pour le langage nécrousé, ce
langage, ce pseudo langage de plus en
plus et ça commence a vite commencé ça a
vite essaimé de plus en plus occuper le
champ symbolique iconique hein,
c'est-à-dire des un champ iconique, un
champ de l'image, un champ de la
représentation dont on ne sera plus la
nature, l'origine, ce que j'appelle dans
mon livre d'une façon très simple un
régime de l'indistinction généralisée.
Or, je vois que tu veux m'interrompre et
tu as bien raison. Mais or,
j'avais envie de dire mon cher Sky, non
pas mon cher Sky, bien sûr mon cher Sky,
toujours mon cher Sky, tu es un ami. Mes
chers amis, mes chers amis, la société
ce ne sont pas que des principes et des
valeurs communes. On le sait bien, il y
en a de et on les respecte de moins en
moins. Ce qui ce qui crée les la
désorientation contemporaine, ce qui
nous emmène à à de moins en moins
respecter des règles et des lois
communes parce qu'on on croit plus en
leur valeur. Et et ça ça crée du
trouble, ça crée de la violence, ça crée
de la désorientation, ça crée le fait
d'être tout le temps ramené à soi-même
et dans des phénomènes de ce que j'ai
appelé isolement collectif. La société
c'est aussi des référents communs, c'est
aussi des textes, des images, des
compréhensions communes qui organisent
quoi ? Le fait de pouvoir se comprendre
relativement à des référents partagés.
au courant qu'on subit depuis 2000 de la
téléréalité
à grande dose de de de débilité qu'on
abruti notre société.
Oui. Oui. Mais mais là là là tu parles
d'autre chose.
Non mais tu parles d'éléments commun de
référentiel
de référent commun. référent commun,
c'est si nous avons une photo de Biden à
la Maison Blanche ou d'un de photo
d'un professeur dans une classe, on
comprend à peu près tous la même chose.
C'est ça le référent commun, c'est que
des textes,
c'est la subjectivité. Chacun comprend
de façon singulière les choses, mais il
y a des référents communs qui nous
permettent de nous déterminer en commun.
Mais nous déterminer comment ? Dans la
singularité, dans la subjectivité.
dans la liberté,
dans l'analyse
et dans la contradic et dans la
contradiction.
Donc c'est du référent commun. Or ce à
quoi ce qui ce qui ce qui s'annonce
c'est le fait que mais ça c'est une
catastrophe civilisationnelle, c'est une
catastrophe de ce que suppose être en
société mais plus encore ce que suppose
la relation que chacun a avec autrui et
le monde. C'est-à-dire en gros qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ce que je dis là ? Mais
ça doit nous amener nous tous à
réfléchir à cela. Tu comprends ? Ah, je
termine, je termine sur ça. Tu me
laisseras pas ne pas terminer. Ça veut
dire que
ça veut dire que
on est seul, il y a plus de confiance.
On n plus de confiance. N alors non
seulement on a plus de confiance et donc
plus que j'ai plus confiance,
j'intensifie. Je je continue à
construire des récits, des pseudor
référents,
des choses que j'ai envie de dire qui
sont qu'à partir de mon propre parce que
ces systèmes sont des systèmes enclins à
nous jouer d'autrui. C'est ça qui qui
est aussi à la mesure de la gravité de
tout ce que j'ai énoncé là. Ce sont des
systèmes qui sont enclins à faire passer
nos propres vues, nos propres lubis au
profit de référent de principes commun
qui appellerait quoi normalement
historiquement ? Et c'est cela qui
malheureusement n'a cessé de
s'amoindrir.
Non, absolument qui appellerait à nous
déterminer en commun. Or, ce que cela
organise, c'est un un
phénomène presque d'ilotisation, tu
comprends ? Il de de de nous remettre à
ces systèmes, des systèmes qui en
l'utilisant amoindrisent la confiance.
en moindurissant la confiance et en
étant dans une surdité, un aveuglement
relativement à ce qui a lieu, et bien on
est dans une désorientation amplifiée et
et dans une et je le redis dans dans on
est dans une vie sans plus de filet, on
n plus confiance, on ne sait plus et
nous allons vers cela. Je t'ai dit 2023
je vous dis nous tous, vous tous nous
tous parce que ce que je dis là c'est
nous tous. Tu sais quand je parle, c'est
pas que moi en réalité, c'est pas que
moi, c'est des principes fondamentaux,
c'est des choses qui nous regardent.
Est-ce qu'on voit-on
le passage de la postvérité en gros ? Ce
qu'on appérité,
complotisme en gros. en très gros pour
faire vite les choses
voilà pour faire très très vite les
choses hein très très vite de 2001 euh
les premières théories complotistes
massives bien avant ça
non mais évidemment mais je fais
l'historique en très gros et puis je
fais un très gros saut avec le fait de
post vériter
le Brexit et Trump
hein et que ça n'a cessé de s'amplifier
et de créer quoi de la surdité
croissante de la brutalisation
croissante des rapports le fait que on a
plus de référents commun. Non seulement
n'a plus de référents commun, mais cet
ordre médiatique, politique, économique
en ordre, non seulement on n'y croit
plus, mais on va lui régler son compte.
L'idée c'est pas de lui régler son
compte, c'est quand même de construire
en commun à toutes les échelles de la
société des modalités divergentes et qui
répondent mieux à nos aspirations. Là,
nous vivons le moment où les années
20167 et toute cette toute cette j'ai
envie de dire désorientation mais aussi
souffrance que nous avons vécu de dire
"Mais on se comprend plus, la
psychiatrie parle, la psychiatrie occupe
le terrain, les haines occupent le
terrain et des choses abjectes peuvent
s'exprimer comme étant relevant de
vérité ou de choses admises."
Et bien mes chers amis, ce n'est que le
début du début avec les images
génératives. Ce n'est que le début en
terme de sur simple instruction
écris-moi un texte qui va dénoncer
certaines personnes, qui va déverser
toutes les haines et qui va être très
bien écrit, hein, un langage pur, hein,
quasi parfait, effrayant, hein, pardon.
Jouristque, presque journalistique.
Presque journalistique ou en tous les
cas qui va être glaçant. Je peux vous
annoncer qu'il va être glaçant,
c'est-à-dire des paroles de haine
prétendument
purifiquement parfaitement écrite,
drappé dans l'étendard de la
sans faute d'orthographe sans parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de faes d'orthographe
pour les personnes qui en général
10 orthographie
voilà ça va être glaçant mais pas
seulement l'environnement symbolique
voiton le présent qui vient c'est-à-dire
je peux parier sans me tromper et si tu
veux on prend rendez-vo vous 2023
euh 2000 pardon, j'ai compté 2 ans. 2020
dans ma tête, j'ai compté 2 ans. 2025
2026 il va être quasi majoritaire et là
vous allez voir ce que midjourney
d'Ali et toute cette économie qui en
réalité parce queil faut quand même le
rappeler. Est-ce que ça tout ce qui se
passe là, ce que je décris à grand
trait, est-ce que ça relève d'un projet
de société concerné ?
Est-ce qu'on a décidé cela en société ?
Je prends la parole.
Je je termine sur cela. Non non. C'est
un modèle unilatéral qui provient
unilatéral parce que ça ne provient que
du de de d'une certaine industrie devenu
hégémonique qui développe ces systèmes
dans une indifférence, dans un mépris
voire dans un euh une une indifférence
obsène relativement aux conséquences
civilisationnelles. Et nous nous nous
acceptons cela et au nom de l'utilité n
nous nous c'est le cheval de 3 de tout
ce que je dis là et
et ça s'impose comme allant de soi et
comme relevant du cours de l'histoire.
Or mon travail justement si on revient à
30 secondes à moi, c'est de signaler que
ce n'est pas le cours naturel des
choses. Ce sont des choses fabriquées et
qui appellent la mise en conscience et
la mise en et la mise en action de la
société. Alors, tu as une question à me
poser. J'aurais encore une chose une
dernière chose extrêmement importante à
dire sur le régime de l'image et avec
les images génératives extrêmement
importantes. Bon, je te coupe un peu, je
te relance un peu.
À l'heure actuelle, on a une société
occidentale qui commence à tout sauter,
capoter, cludiquer, à se remettre en
question d'une façon difficile. Le
réchauffement climatique,
c'est la désorientation,
l'hyperconsommation, l'hyperconsommation
énergétique, la stabilité des cours de
bourse, la capacité des organismes de
retraite à payer énergie,
la vie sans filet, la vie sans filet
individuellement collectif,
on se retrouve avec, on va dire 40 ou 50
ans d'un projet civilisationnel qui est
en train de calencher. Hm
hm.
Tout le monde se fout sur la Je vais
être vulgaire. se fout sur la gueule que
ce soit localement, géopolitiquement
parlant, les voisins, les continents,
les blocs à gauche et à droite,
ça part en sucette. On a une population
qui a été euh
manipulée par la politique, par manipul
par de la subordation de vote. Je suis
le président du pouvoir d'achat, votez
pour moi, ça ira mieux demain et je t'en
passe des
je sais pas, moi je dirais jamais
manipulé. qui impose
qui impose de façon abusive ses vues,
c'est autre chose.
Qui impose de façon abusive ses vu ? On
peut imposer d'une façon abusive ses vu
mais là tu m'emmènes ailleurs he ber là
moi j'étais dans le générative et les
images hein.
Donc on peut se faire abuser si on n pas
les armes pour se défendre. Tu es
d'accord avec moi ? Quand une politique
quand les politiciens abusent les gens,
c'est qu'en face les gens ils sont cons
à bouffer du foin. Euh ou alors ou alors
ils s'élèvent ou alors ils opèrent des
contrer récits plus ou moins de plus ou
moins de valeur.
D'accord. Donc on a une société qui va
être obligée de faire face
à des pénuries énergétiques.
Donc si tu as une intelligence
artificielle qui peut être évité d'avoir
un blackout généralisé parce que bon ils
ont pas anticipé mais il faut quand même
survivre. Il faut quand même que le
diabétique, le mec qui est sous
respirateur, il bon bah tu comprends, il
faut que ça continue.
Bon normal, faut faut quand même peu
normal faut quand même que ça continue.
H
il y a pas que des défauts à
l'intelligence artificielle. le le le
dermatologue qui va pouvoir faire 25000
consultations plus rapidement, qui va
désengorger sa file d'attente parce
qu'il y a plus de dermatologue parce que
comme les médecins sont pas assez payés
et ben ils ont plus envie de faire
médecine parce qu'ils s'exposent à des
procès. J'ai compris, on a compris Scal,
on a on a très bien compris. Je vais y
revenir parce que tu fais bien l'avocat
du diable hein.
Non mais non mais c'est pas qu'avocat du
diable. Tu soulignes des choses
importantes sur lesquelles je vais
revenir parce que je vais signaler une
autre équation que personne ne dit et
que j'ai théorisé pour dans ce dernier
livre et que je vais continuer à
théoriser. Tu vas voir là, je fais du
teasing. On va y revenir dans quelques
instants. Je veux continuer si tu veux
bien parce que ce que tu dis, il y a
beaucoup de juste.
Et ben non, je veux pas.
Comment ?
Attends, vas-y, continue.
Il y a beaucoup de juste dans ce que tu
dis.
Mais je te Non, je te propose de
procéder par ordre. J'ai un certain
ordre pour que on va y venir sur cela
parce que l'idée c'est pas la tu
comprends c'est pas l'intelligence
artificielle dans son ensemble c'est pas
ça
c'est la société
non non non non non non c'est ce qui se
c'est évidemment la société mais c'est
c'est des fonctionnalités c'est des
missions
et là j'insiste sur des des
fonctionnalités et des missions qui sont
major majoritaires et qui vont qui nous
étouffent qui imposent des ordres sans
qu'on luiême nous-même décider et qui
vont nous amoindrir et non seulement
organiser les choses à notre place, mais
éteindre la flamme de vie et la flamme
de génie qui qui sont qui sont en nous.
Je reviens donc je vais ce que tu viens
de dire là, je te promets, c'est dans un
coin de ma tête et dans 5 minutes, je
vais y revenir. J'étais un peu fatigué
au début parce que je bosse trop mais là
ça y est, je suis en grande forme. Ne
vous inquiétez pas, on va développer les
choses avec le temps qui nous reste. Euh
euh le donc j'ai appelé avec le le le
génératives et les images, j'ai appelé
le régime de l'indistinction, hein. Le
régime de l'indistinction. D'ailleurs,
il y a un chapitre du bouquin euh que va
publier le monde diplô euh sur une page
dans le l'édition de novembre où il y a
ce chapitre qui va être publié,
c'estàdire le régime de l'indistinction.
Ils ont considéré que je pointais des
choses visamment graves pour le mettre
sur une pleine page, ce qu'on appelle
les bonnes feuilles, hein. Donc, il y a
un chapitre du livre dans le diplô de
novembre, ce qui m'a ravi parce que il
faut qu'on saisisse par tous les moyens
ce qui se joue. Ce régime de
l'indistinction, c'est d'une gravité. Tu
peux donner plein d'adjectifs hein
civilisationnel, social, anthropologique
sur la la chacun comme on se voit. Bon,
il y a autre chose. Il y a le fait que
euh dessine-moi un mouton saint exupéri.
C'est-à-dire que sur simple instruction,
on va pouvoir
euh dire
"Fais-moi ma petite nouvelle nouvelle
littéraire, fais-moi euh mon petit
roman, fais-moi ma petite histoire." Un
enfant pourra dire de 5 ans, "Fais-moi
ma petite histoire.
Fais-moi ma vie !"
Non, non, c'est pas "Fais-moi ma vie là.
Fais-moi mon régime symbolique. Fais-moi
ma petite série qui me convient, que
j'aimerais voir moi. Fais-moi mon petit
film qui pourra même durer 7h ou 20
minutes. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça ?
Ça veut dire que ça ne suffit pas de se
croire le roi du monde avec les
technologies de l'expressivité de
nous-même, de l'exposition de nous-même
et du fait d'avoir le monde à porortter
de main
ou de parler comme
ou de ou pardon
voilà ou de parler comme et le
maintenant nous avons nous allons dans
un environnement dans un dans un étose
dans une façon de nous conduire où nous
allons prétendument nous illusionner sur
le fait d'avoir un régime symbo
symbolique, c'est l'enfer, hein. Ce que
je dis là, c'est l'enfer qui va répondre
à nos propres envies, à nos propres
caprice. C'est-à-dire, qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça ? C'est-à-dire la mise à
distance de la culture. Entendue comme
quoi la culture ? Et ben, c'est le grand
autre, c'est-à-dire c'est les œuvres.
les les la culture, les œuvres, on
entend les livres, on entend la
littérature, on entend la philosophie,
on entend le cinéma, on entend l'art, on
entend le grand leg culturel de
l'humanité depuis la nuit des temps. et
bien de plus en plus qui est appelé à
être de plus de plus en plus repoussé
hein les grandes œuvres les œuvres de
l'esprit comme dit Paul Valéri au
profite donc autrui qu'on va repousser
autrui entendu comme un vecteur de
bouleversement de surprise qui n'a
jamais lu un livre en disant ça a été
une claque qui n'a jamais vu un film dit
bah ma vie n'a plus jamais été comme
comme avant
qui n'a jamais lu un poème
qui n'a jamais lu un poème ou une phras
Sky ou une phrase de quelqu'un qui dit
"Mais ça a changé ma vie cette parole."
Mais là c'est un c'est un repli au
carré, le repli dont parlait tout à
l'heure au repli sur le régime
symbolique, c'est-à-dire ne voir que ce
qui nous ferait plaisir ou nous
plairait. C'est-à-dire de mettre à
distance autrui comme puissance de
découverte, de moddification,
de d'exploration de territoires qu'on
aurait jamais envisagé d'explorer tout
seul.
En gros, la culture, c'est qu'il y a des
choses qui sont euh euh euh euh
non pas plus grand que nous parce que
nous sommes tous dans une égalité de
conditions, mais qu'il y a des choses
tellement différentes
que nous et qui peuvent nous emmener à
penser autrement. Ce que dit exactement
Michel Fouco à l'égard de la culture
dit, "Pourquoi on apprend ? Pourquoi on
réfléchit ? Pourquoi on lit des textes
?" Parce que lui disait ça, il disait
"C'est pour apprendre à penser
autrement."
le décentrement par des claques. Tu dis
une phrase, mon dieu, moi tout à l'heure
je vais vous parler d'une phrase parce
que c'est pas le moment. Une phrase qui
m'a mis une claque cet été de Charles
Peg mais c'est pas le moment. Donc c'est
autre, c'est l'autrui. On parlait
d'autrui en terme de de gage de
confiance dans le régime symbolique de
notre distinction mais autrui comme le
grand autre. le grand autre entendu
comme quelqu'un qui a travaillé, qui a
fait des œuvres, qui m'apporte une
richesse d'autrui. Voyons-nous
l'alignement à son petit moi, à son tout
petit mois et et ignorance même dans 7 8
ans, on va dire à la fin de cette
décennie, du fait que il puisse avoir du
texte, il puisse avoir de l'image, il
puisse avoir du son, puisse avoir de la
musique, il puissent avoir Bethoven, il
puissent avoir les Beatles.
autrement que par mon propre instruction
et ce que je ce que je voudrais que ça
qui soit produit. Et là, voit-on ce que
suppose aussi la culture, l'économie de
la culture, la place de l'artiste, du
créateur et et la richesse mutuelle
d'avoir affaire à ce monde-là. et et et
cela c'est le résultat direct du
promptisme généralisé,
de notre paresse fondamentale, de notre
utilitarisme et le fait de
malheureusement de euh de ne pas voir
plus loin
au-delà du présent du court terme de de
notre comme ce que j'ai dit midi à notre
porte et cela est à l'œuvre et cela est
à l'œuvre ce que je dis là avec un enjeu
fondamental de la société qui va nous
regarder qui en lien direct avec la
question qui a été posée tout à l'heure
Voilà, c'est les métiers.
C'est les métiers. C'est-à-dire, il est
très éloquent que Samatman qui est comme
tu sais et le cfondateur d'Open et donc
qui a l'origine de qui est la compagnie
qui a produit qui a conçu le chat GPT.
Il est très éloquent qu'en mars en mai
2023, moi j'ai cru un canular. J'ai cru
un canular. Je l'ai dit dans le bouquin.
Si tu l'as lu, tu t'en souviens
peut-être. Mais je sais que tu l'as lu,
tu m'as dit que ça t'avait beaucoup
intéressé même plus que ça. Bref,
moi je me suis régalé. Bon merci
Bertrand ch je me suis régalé aussi avec
le bouquin de Laurent Alexandre.
Bon bah
est-ce que tu l'as lu le bouquet de
Laurent Alexandre ?
Je n'ai pas le temps. Je préfère lire
Charles Peggy ou Gunter Anders.
Moi j'ai demandé à Laurent Alexandre.
J'ai demandé à Laurent qu'il bouquin.
Mais il me lit. Je sais qu'il me lit
puisqu'il me l'a dit puisquil avait
trouvé dans une émission de radio avec
Natacha Polini sur Paris Première. J'ai
une date terrible de de tout. Il m'avait
dit la syonisation du monde c'est
formidable. Mais c'est je vais continuer
là si tu veux bien les métiers. Ça
matman
que tout le monde a reçu euh euh tapis
rouge hein. Même Macron, j'ai trop de
choses à dire mais je vais essayer de
les dire parce que sur Macron il dép le
tapis rouge un peu pour
Bon non mais alors il a j'ai cru un
canular, il a fait une conférence de
presse avec ses équipes en mai 2023. On
va calmer les foules parce que ça sent
quand même un peu le la forêt qui brûle
tout ça. Il a il a ils ont avec ses
équipes travaillé mais c'est
extraordinaire hein euh sur les 34
métiers qui étaient menacés de
d'extinction ou mis en péril par les
développements de lien génératif. La
liste, elle est extraordinaire. C'est
réparateurs de de motocyclettes,
plongeurs, athlète, sportif de haut
niveau, installateur de ligne
électrique. Tu t'es dit mais ils ont bu
là les gars, c'est c'est quoi cette
histoire ? Il il eut était bien plus
instructif et honnête. Lui qui en0 en
2015 disait aux étudiants de Harvard
qu'il y avait pas un matin où il ne se
levait pas sans penser au nombre
d'emplois qu'il allait détruire. il a
quand même dit ça et il e bien plus
honnête et euh et juste de décliner la
liste des métiers appelés à être mise en
péril et moi je la fais et elle peut
être elle peut être égrainée sur de
longues pages.
Il y a acteur porno dedans ou pas ?
Il y a quoi
acteur porno dedans ? En tous les cas,
il y a euh il y a tu parlais de
journaliste, il y a évidemment le
journalisme, c'est-à-dire on sait que de
plus en plus le journalisme utilise des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
pour produire des textes de base. Je
renvoie à Build, tu sais le groupe
allemand build qui encore en mai,
décidément mai dernier, il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses, a décidé de avec une
novel langue managériale géniale, hein,
pour soucis de rationalisation de
modalités de d'organisation de nos
groupes de presse et cetera. Ils ont
licencié mais en quelques mois hein Chat
GPT euh vu chat GPT les génératives un/3
de leur de leurs effectifs mais la liste
est très longue hein à terme le figure
du professeur qu'elle sera telle
quantité de métier d'expertise expert
comptable
doubleur enfin métier d'assurance métier
de banque
interprète
interprète interprète j'ai donné une
conférence à Moden Italie il y a 10
jours et en direct j'ai dit mais vous
savez cet interprète fait qui fait en
temps réel enfin en direct
l'interprétation qu'il le fait avec ses
qualités, son génie et et en donnant une
consonance particulière subjective à la
langue italienne. Dans 2 3 ans, elle
sera peut-être remplacée. Des gens des
centaines de personnes ont applaudi en
sentant que c'était grave ce qui se
jouait. Or, ce que nous avons c'est ce
qu'il se passe, c'est que nous ne voyons
pas parce qu'il y a quelque chose de
double bind, c'est-à-dire au nom du
primat économique, on se dit c'est le il
faut être dans les LLM, les les large
language model et li générative, mais on
ne voit pas dans le le diable est dans
comment on dit dans le fruit, on dit ça
ou le verre est dans le fruit, on ne
voit pas. Il y a une doxa qui dit faut
aller vers ça. C'est cette économie là
qu'il faut développer. ce qu'a dit
Macron à Vivateek hein Vivateek 2023 je
devais le voir hein je vous raconterai
ça tout à l'heure Emmanuel Macron et qui
a dit
rappelle-lui la prochaine fois que on
fait que lui envoyer des SMS
bon mais je vous je vous expliquerai si
on a le temps, je veux pas être trop
long parce que là c'est des choses très
importantes et qui a dit Vivatec 2023
donc cette grande messe comme il y en a
tant qui impose des choses qui qui crée
une des normes des normes industrielles
mais aussi qui qui qui
formate un esprit pris du temps sur le
fait que voilà l'horizon économique
industriel mais aussi mais aussi de de
conduite
inéluctable de notre temps et qui a dit
Vivatech la France doit être faire un
double d'open et high c'est-à-dire un
double d'open et high de systèmes qui
vont
non pas comme le le phénomène de
repétisation des des métiers à haute
pénibilité comme il y a eu au détour au
tournant des années 80 notamment dans
l'industrie automobile dont Vous pouvez
dire que c'était à des finalités
vertueuses, hein, que des corps qui en
bavaient soient remplacés par des robots
pour créer de nouveaux métiers où les
corps soient moins moins mis à l'épreuve
ou moins
éprouvé.
C'était juste pour la tune mais bon.
Bon mais évidemment c'était de
l'optimisation mais en tous les cas il y
a eu ce mouvement là de robotisation qui
était entamé au Japon au milieu des
années 70 et qu'après gagner la la terre
entière. Là, c'est des métiers non pas
seulement à haute compétences
cognitives, c'est des métiers qui
mobilisent nos intellects, qui mobilise
notre créativité, qui crée du plaisir à
la tâche, qui crée des des formes
quotidiennes et continues de socialité,
qui crée des rapports quotidiens avec
les êtres, qui créent aussi des
phénomènes ce qu'on vit de moins en
moins d'estime de soi parce que
journaliste, c'est un métier qui qui
crée l'estime de soi, hein. Quoi ? Quoi
? Comment ?
Comment ?
Journaliste
mais quantité de et bien et plein
d'autres plein d'autres métiers. Or ces
systèmes d'IA génératif c'est sur simple
instruction vont vont vont répondre à
des tâches dans tous les champs de la
vie. Je peux dire je termine juste je
peux dire
je peux dire dessine-moi ma maison. D
Non mais tu vois ce que je viens de dire
dessine-moi ma maison.
D'accord. Et ensuite tu vas aller voir
un architect Et ensuite tu vas aller
voir un architecte. Tu vas lui dire "Bon
écoute, il y a il y a machin open machin
qui m'a dessiné ma maison. Qu'est-ce que
tu en penses ?
S'il reste des architectes
en terme de structurel, en terme de
machin, en terme OK là on est dans une
société, on est combien de milliards sur
terre ? Est-ce que la société que tu me
décris
Oui. Non, je décris pas, je
diagnostique,
je sais pas. Non non non non non Skyrom
c'est pas un côté c'est je fais du
diagnostic là il y a rien de puriste et
et je fais du diagnostic sur le fait
parce que c'est le titre d'un chapitre
de mon livre l'adaptation est une
soumission à force de nous adapter à
toute cette logique là c'est une
soumission à l'autométisation croissante
des affaires humaines à l'abandon et au
renoncement de nos facultés les plus
fondamentales. Ça c'est du diagnostic
pas du purisme. Quand j'entends des
profs quand une personne qui a fait une
tribune dans le monde qui m'a invité à
Lyon, je sais pas pourquoi m'a invité
une conférence dans le cas d'un festival
en janvier dernier qui dit "On va
pouvoir mieux apprendre
mieux apprendre avec les élèves en usant
de chat GPT." En gros, elle a rien
compris. C'est une adaptation qui relève
la soumission, c'est-à-dire l'idée de
l'inéluctable et que des technologies
développées uniquement en vue de générer
des profits, au lieu de saisir la mort
qui est dans ça, le le renoncement à
nous-même, on continue de croire qu'on
va pouvoir procéder de cette novel
langue là, de cette doxa laquelle ? De
la prétendue complémentarité homme
machine. C'est ça qu'on nous vend depuis
une quinzaine d'années, qui est
entretenu par les par les cabinets de de
consulting, c'est ne vous inquiétez pas,
on va travailler encore mieux. Arrêtez,
arrêtons de croire en cette novel
langue. Aller demander aux tiers au
milliers de personnes chez Bild s'ils
sont dans la complémentarité machine et
allez demander mon cher mon cher Sky à
ces héros de notre époque là il devrait
y en avoir plus si au scénaristes
d'Hollywood si les systèmes d'IA pour
Netflix et dans le cinéma qui ont déjà
des capacités à pouvoir créer des des
scénaris adaptés aux demandes aussi
des scénaris non scénaris au pluriel des
scénaris adaptés à chacun ou adapté aux
demandes ce qui est déjà à l'œuvre mais
ça c'est ses pensées avec des humains.
On se dit, il faudrait répondre à telle
demande, à telle aire du temps, à telle
statistique de consommation sur telle
série qui fait qu'on continuerait on
on veut influencer notre opinion
publique.
Ouais, enfin je parle pas non, je parle
pas d'influence, je parle non de
d'intérêt économique, de donner ce que
les les de produire ce qui des choses
qui pourraient encore produire plus
d'attention aux séries et au scénari.
C'est une tendance à l'œuvre à Hollywood
et de plus en
du fait de l'avènement de Netflix depuis
une quinzaine d'années mais qui n'est
pas à l'œuvre dans tout le cinéma et
bien heureusement mais les scénaristes
ont bien vu venir la chose et les
acteurs ils ont bien vu venir.
C'est-à-dire que avec les ag génératives
il y a une bascule. Je l'ai dit sur quoi
? C'est ça qu'il faut entendre. C'est ça
qu'on entend pas sur nos facultés
intellectuelles et créatives.
Mais tu as vu ce qu'il en reste ?
Non. Laisse-moi terminer. Laisse-moi
terminer. Arrête de me dire les soins ce
qu'il en reste. C'est pas les soins,
explique-nous ce qu'il en reste. C'est
ça que nous devons cultiver. Mais là, je
vais y venir dans quelques instants. Et
les scénaristes
au lieu de gober les choses ou au lieu
d'être dans l'adaptation qui c'est une
soumission, la soumission ça veut dire
c'est fini. C'estd c'est notre mort à
programmé la soumission de métier hein.
Ils ont dit comme Albert Camu euh dans
l'homme révolté, vous allez trop loin,
vous arrêtez. Là, ça s'arrête. On ne
veut pas de ça dans nos métiers. parce
qu'on sait très bien, c'était au
printemps dernier, on sait très bien
dans au rythme où vont les choses, au
rythme de sophistication et au rythme de
cynisme de l'industrie aussi, de
sinisme, c'est-à-dire qui est pas
d'humain, mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en tape
pour dire de façon familière, n'est-ce
pas ? qu'est-ce qu'on son contrefous et
que des des des scénaristes vont pouvoir
être hyper adaptés à la demande et à la
demande de chacun. C'est à la limite
c'est l'autre côté du de la phase de ce
que je disais tout à l'heure. Moi, je me
commande ma propre série ou alors
l'industrie pour essayer de survivre va
donner des séries va produire des séries
toujours plus personnalisées en vue de
ne pas de qu'on les abandonne pas. Et
eux ont dit ça suffit, c'est non. Or, je
crois je crois que
cela c'est une là il y a un cas de
figure, il y a un cas d'école sur le
fait de quoi ? de conscience de
personnes qui ont vu venir les choses.
C'est-à-dire, c'était pas au printemps
hein le remplacement par les I
génératives hein, c'était pas que pour
ça, c'était aussi pour des conditions
salariales. Les acteurs aussi, mais les
acteurs aussi se sont mis en grève hein
parce que tu sais bien que sur simple
instruction, le promptisme généralisé,
c'est les 20 prochaines années,
parenthèse
capitale. Si nous n'y prenons garde, je
vais venir dans quelques instants. le
fait que on va pouvoir faire produire
des acteurs prétendus entre mil
guillemets synthétiques. Donc ces
gens-là ont senti cela pour plein de
raisons qui serait intéressant
d'analyser parce qu'ils sont proches de
la SC Convallé parce qu'ils voient ce
modèle de d'algorithmisation de de
l'écriture des scénarios et ils ont eu
le courage la force de pas dire "Oui, on
va s'adopter, ça va nous permettre de
mieux adosser nos pratiques, de mieux
les développer, de mieux comprendre des
choses." Franchement toute cette novel
qui est inacceptable c'est pas qu'elle
est inacceptable qu' ne devrait jamais
nous leurer qui ne doit pas nous leurer
et ça c'est en en lien direct ce que je
dis là avec un des grands kiproco de
l'époque et là je voudrais que tu me
laisses 2 minutes pour développer un des
grands qui proco de l'époque parce que
relativement à ce diagnostic que je fais
euh parfois on me dit ou alors des gens
qui n'en ont pas conscience qui ont
conscience de dérives
ou de fait que certaines choses
procèdent par excès, mais que quand même
on veut faire un double d'open et que
quand même on veut continuer cette
économie de de la donnée, des
plateformes et de l'intelligence
artificielle et de l'orientation
algorithmique de nos existences
individuelles et et collectives et du
fait de de de nous déprendre de nos
facultés les plus fondamentales.
On dit oui pour certains points, il ne
faut pas s'inquiéter parce qu'il y a il
y a une quelque chose qu'on nous
présente qui est présenté et contre le
contre lequel je me pose mais
radicalement frontalement qui nous est
présenté comme la panassée de points
la régulation. Alors si vous voulez un
un typeroco, une grande enflure de
l'époque, c'est la régulation. Je
m'explique, la régulation d'abord, elle
vient toujours à postériori. On a vu
tout ce qui s'est passé, l'économie de
la donnée, les plateformes, on a vu avec
Amazon, Uber, on a vu tout ça c'estàd
avec le renseignement aussi
avec quantité de choses, avec des
modalités de surveillance, enfin bref,
avec quantité de choses. C'est-à-dire
c'est une fois que les choses sont
profondément instituées, que ça a créé
quantité de dégâts, on se dit "On va un
peu s'y coltiner, hein, le régulateur va
un peu faire du pansement. Euh euh
si je
si je mets en critique cette cette
façon dont est présenté la régulation
comme étant un pensement possible, c'est
au nom d'une nouvelle équation que je
propose. Et là je te demande mon cher
Sky, tu ne m'interromps pas d'une autre
équation que je propose.
Dans 2 minutes, je te pète t les genoux
hein,
que j'ai que j'ai théorisé et on va et
on va comprendre à quel point ça opère
un déplacement qui devrait nous
éclairer. Ce n'est plus procédé parce
que la régulation procède par cela mais
nos esprits aussi en sont arrivés à
procéder selon une équation binaire.
Les risques prétendus et les avantages
prétendus. C'est toujours au nom de cela
que pensé la régulation à l'intérieur
d'une tradition, je vais être très
précis là, très précis, du droit positif
dans les démocraties
libérales qui ne privilégie le droit
positif, c'est le droit arbitraire,
c'està-dire le droit qui aurait pu être
autrement et qui est déterminé dans les
démocraties libérales par le primat
économique. C'est ça le droit positif
dans dans les démocraties libérales et
nos le la régulation relativement au
développement sans cesse croissant des
technologies numériques et l'étendue des
excès que ça produit
et des dérives,
elle est toujours considérée par le
régulateur mais aussi nos esprits à
l'intérieur de l'équation
avantage prétendu
risque et inconvénient en supposant quoi
? En supposant quoi ? Si on se penche
sur les risques prétendus hein que
certains le régulateur
saisiraient identifieraient
et bien les choses seraient à peu près
réglées. On serait pas loin du meilleur
de monde. Et le processus que j'ai
décrit, c'est-à-dire d'automatisation
sans cesse croissant des affaires
humaines, d'organisation hyper
rationalisée de la société et de
marchandisation intégrale de la vie ne
fera en réalité que s'intensifier. Je
propose une autre équation toute autre.
C'est c seu seule si on veut du baire.
C'est pas ma mes modalités
conceptuelles, mais si vous voulez du
binaire, je suis un peu ironique là
hein, mais si on veut du baire, c'est
une équation entre là où nous avons la
main
et là où nous n'avons pas la main. C'est
ça l'équation que nous auraient dû nous
que nous aurions dû nous poser depuis
une quinzaine d'années. Amazon dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure dans les entrepôts,
on a la main, on n pas la main. Au nom
des principes juridiques,
politico-juridiqu fondamentaux qui nous
animent, on n pas la main, c'est
inacceptable. Et pour et là, tu as dit,
je t'ai dit tout à l'heure et et on a de
moins en moins la main. Le fait est
qu'en société, on a de moins en moins la
main parce que des systèmes de plus en
plus organisent les choses ce dont des
des villes u des visées donc que j'ai
décrit tout à l'heure et euh et euh je
n'ai pas oublié ce que ce que ce que ce
que la question que tu m'as posé tout à
l'heure ou la réflexion, la remarque.
Euh le fait est que euh je ne nie pas
et là il faut entendre ce que je vais
dire. Je ne ni pas par exemple
euh l'heure depuis une dizaine d'années,
plus encore aujourd'hui est à la
conception l'élaboration de super
calculateurs.
Alors c'est intéressant ce que je vais
exposer là de super calculateurs
qui vont permettre
tout ce l'accélération,
l'intensification jusqu'à terme à une
dimension quantique d'ordinateur
quantique. C'est-à-dire là, on va
basculer dans une autre dimension, hein.
C'est-à-dire l'automatisation et le fait
que oui, il y aura une une précience de
de de toute la réalité du monde, de
toutes nos réalités par des systèmes de
plus en plus sophistiqué. Mais des super
calculateurs permettent quoi parmi tant
d'autres choses ? Ils permettent
il permett voilà ils permettent
d'affiner
euh des modèles de de dans la soufflerie
aéronautique de
prévision climatique
des prévisions climatiques, d'affiner
des modèles d'interprétation de de
d'effets secondaires de molécules sur
des sur des pathologies sur des types
particuliers. Bref, ils permettent une
infinité de fonctionnalités qui peuvent
être cas par cas, c'est à évaluer,
peuvent être bienvenu. Mais tous ces cas
de figure, il il il ils font quoi ? Ils
procèdent de quoi ? Du fait que nous
avons la main. Nous pouvons nous décider
tiens là il y a des calculs, des
résultats qui nous permettent de nous
décider en fonction au nom de critères
d'utilitaris de de de perfectionnement
de la santé enfin de critères sanitaire
de perfectionnement de molécules. C'est
cela qu'on devrait c'est cette équation
là et cette équation elle changerait du
tout au tout notre perception des
phénomènes. Parce que je dois signaler
que relativement à tout ce qui se passe
avec les les développements de sans
cesse croissant de l'intelligence
artificiel
depuis 2 3 ans, on nous dit mais nous
dans nos pays européens ne vous
inquiétez pas on est en train de
travailler sur un corpus législatif qui
va tout changer et ils vont voir ce
qu'ils vont voir. Ça s'appelle l'UE Act
l'UE Act. Le celui qui est aux commande
de ça, c'est Thierry Breton qui a été
aux commande pendant 10 ans d'Athos
euh d'Ahos, c'est-à-dire une société
française
qui euh
a été vendu un peu.
Bon, alors je vais je vais en dire
quelques mots sur ça, mais c'est pas
l'essentiel. dont le cœur à l'époque
était entre autres de développer des
supercalculateurs mais surtout de
développer de de s'engager dans la
course aux ordinateurs quantiques. Ce
monsieur pendant 10 ans, il n'a fait que
s'inscrire dans cette logique économique
industrielle de cette doxala
d'automatisation sans cesse croissante
de de de la société. Ce monsieur
parenthèse a fait des acquisitions
désastreuses qui se sont révélées à
postériorie désastreuse et il a vendu au
bon moment tant mieux pour lui départ et
il est passé à la Commission européenne
par magie
par magie et d'ailleurs à aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
avec Porto c'est Arabis
voilà et surtout aujourd'hui 19 octobre
j'ai lu dans le journal que la semaine
dernière le PDG au vu de toutes les
catastrophes d'acquisition désastreuse
qui qui remonte à Thierry Breton a été
démissionné au profit d'un autre PDG
parce que ATOS ne cesse de de vivre des
des difficultés depuis que ce monsieur a
fait quantité de de de mauvais a pris
quantité de mauvaises décisions a eu le
flair de
décisions qui n'ont pas été suffisamment
non des non des décisions d'acquisition
de de visant à aller vers l'ordinateur
quantique des super calculateurs avec
des strat bon mais je suis pas là pour
parler de ça il a très bien vendu et
tout tant mieux Pour lui, ce qui est
comique, ce qui n'est pas que comique,
ce qui est tragic comique, mais qu'il
faut souligner, c'est que ce monsieur
maintenant depuis quelques années joue
au grand chérif, hein. C'est-à-dire, il
nous dit "Attention, le temps du laisser
faire c'est terminé, je vais m'opposer
au grand gourou de la Silicon Vallée et
Elon Musk." Et donc, ils sont en train
de travailler depuis quelques années sur
l'UE Act euh qui euh qui se trompe du
tout au tout.
C'est-à-dire qui se trompe du tout auto.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il procède de
l'équation encore avantage inconvénient,
risque inconvénient et et à tel point
que comment ils ont procédé. Non mais
vraiment ils n'y comprennent rien.
Vraiment c'est gravissime ce que je vais
dire là. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Ils
ont ils ont procédé par une prétendue
échelle de risque he une prétendue
échelle de risque, c'est extraordinaire.
Donc il est dit le risque premier c'est
qu'il faudrait pas qu'avec les systèmes
de développement d'intelligence des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
l'Europe tombe dans le crédit social
chinois. Oui, on peut supposer que dans
nos démocraties européennes, nous
n'allons pas aller vers une évaluation
continue par les gouvernements des de
nos conduites de toutes nos de nos actes
de la vie quotidienne et de terminer des
avantages en fonction et déterminer de
la notification des des notes hein de
chaque individu. Euh, on n pas besoin de
vous pour ça hein. La société, on peut
supposer qu'elle se elle se
mobiliserait, elle se lèverait pour pour
dire non à cela. On peut
ça c'est pas le cas du tout. C'est pas
on peut supposer mais c'est pas ça.
Regarde civilité il y a personne qui
je veux dire Sky ce que je veux dire
c'est que déterminer cette échelle de
risque il y a rien de plus facile et on
se fout de nous parce que on n pas
besoin de de de l'Union européenne de
définir ça parce que
peut-être là où tu te trouves.
Non je termine parce que ça c'est dans
le ce que tu ne sais peut-être pas mais
tu le sais c'est que c'est dans les
textes constitutionnels de tous les pays
et on n pas besoin de l'Europe. L'Europe
c'est ce qui est supraconstitutionnel.
Donc qu'est-ce qui donc on n pas besoin
de l'Europe pour ça
il a rien auudess de la constitution
française.
Bon alors on peut en tous les cas pour
pour nous
pour certaines dimensions
pour certaines dimensions et et tout
cela est dans toutes les constitutions
des démocraties libérales. Donc on n pas
besoin. En revanche qu'est-ce qu'ils
nous disent ? Et là on marche sur la
tête on marche sur la tête on nous dit
le prétendu grand problème de de
l'époque. Alors sur les données privées,
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais depuis un
moment hein. La vie privée et cetera.
serait bien qu'on se soucie pas que de
notre vie privée mais l'expression de de
de notre liberté, de notre autonomie de
jugement et de notre créativité dans en
société. Mais c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
soulligne dans les dans les dans les
risques élevés
au temps où il doit y avoir attention
attention la moins de discrimination
doit être chassé c'est les biais. Ah
mesdames et messieurs, les billets,
voilà la pseudoconscience critique,
l'exemple le plus emblématique de la
pseudoconscience critique. C'estàd quand
quelqu'un aujourd'hui, que ça soit un
ingénieur ou quelqu'un qui par ses
discours ou par ses ses projets, par ses
productions alimente cette économie,
cette étos de l'automatisation des
affaires humaines, oui, c'est vrai. Il y
a il y a des biais dans les algorithmes.
Par exemple, je parlais de recrutement
tout à l'heure. qu'on va on va se
pencher sur les algorithmes et une fois
qu'on les aura enlevés, donc ça sera pas
des personnes blanches plutôt que noires
ou des femmes plutôt que des que que des
hommes ou des gens de 20 ans plutôt que
de 40 ans qui vont être choisis, ce
serait plutôt des critères objectifs.
Ah, la grande affaire. la grande
affaire, c'est-à-dire une fois qu'on
aurait dégagé, on se on se soucierait de
chasser ces biaiss, et bien c'est le
tapis rouge à l'automatisation des
affaires humaines et à des systèmes qui
gèrent de plus en plus euh des secteurs
collectifs de la société. Je vous donne
un autre exemple
qui m'a fait qui me fait rire, mais je
vais écrire sur cela. Je l'écris mais je
conté produire une tribune sur cela.
Thierry Breton et act dit quoi ? Dit
attention, ces systèmes d'IA générative
se nourrissent
de euh de corpus existants, euh de
texte, d'images, de vidéos. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
On va on doit se soucier de rémunérer
les ayants droits. Non, mais on marche
sur la tête. C'est-à-dire au lieu de
voir le régime de l'indistinction qui
vient, la psychiatrie, le le surcroix de
psychiatrisation qui vient, la se le
seul souci qu'on a, c'est de mieux
répartir la richesse produite. Parce que
il l'a dit lui-même Thierry Breton et et
et tous les régulateurs le disent,
l'idée c'est de soutenir le
développement dans une bonne
acceptabilité sociale des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle de de ce
modèle-là. Donc on va se soucier de
faire en sorte que sur des sur des
questions économiques ou des questions,
allez, je vais dire secondaire,
importantes, mais malgré tout
secondaire,
euh cette cette orientation là, cette
dynamique là puisse continuer à se
développer. C'est-à-dire au lieu de dire
non,
nous ne voulons pas de ces systèmes de
d'intelligence générative au lieu de
nous opposer parce que au nom des
conséquences civilisationnelles, on ne
pense qu'au primat économique, on dit
c'est ça le devenir des 10 prochaines
années, c'est d'aller vers les LLM. Et
donc on va se soucier, tu comprends ? la
marge, on va rémunérer. Et alors, une
fois qu'on va rémunérer, je te pose la
question, ça va ça va ça va empêcher ce
renoncement que j'ai décrit à nous-même,
à nos à l'oubli de à l'oubli de nos
facultés les plus fondamentales et au
régime de de l'indistinction
généralisée. Et sur l'indistinction
généralisée, qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit ?
On va taguer les images.
On va taguer les images générées pour
qu'on puisse les reconnaître. Mais c'est
ne pas voir que c'est un esprit du temps
qui va s'institutionnaliser. C'est ne
pas voir qu'il y a des systèmes d'open
source qui vont se généraliser et qui
vont faire que et bien ça va entrer dans
la norme. Donc ce que je crois c'est que
ce n'est pas du côté du régulateur qu'on
peut compter pour
s'opposer à ce puissant mouvement mais
aussi pour créer pour pour engager des
nouvelles modalités. Comp
alors
faut compter sur qui en un mot tu me
poses la question. Bah je fais du bruit
avec ma bouche.
Alors on peut certainement pas compter
sur la les experts nommés par Emmanuel
Macron dans sa commission il y a un
mois.
On peut on peut compter sur la
population pour ce
alors je je voudrais terminer cela. On
ne peut certainement pas compter sur la
commission d'experts que veut monter
Ursula Van Dernden. Yen
comment
c'est comme la Yen mais
Yedden, j'arrive jamais à prononcer son
nom.
rappelle-toi à la passe tout de suite
laen à la la à la Commission européenne
ou comme Macron qui a monté une
commission n'est-ce pas qui voit des
gens comme Yan Lequin qui travaillent
pour MTA Facebook euh qui participe euh
avec c'est les réseaux de neurones qu'il
a construit qu'il a contribué à
à produire
non mais attends attends attends là
c'est pas une réponse. Je signale
quelque chose de très important là,
c'est-à-dire qu'en République, Emmanuel
Macron monte un prétendu comité
d'experts et en langage juridique et en
République, on appelle ça un conflit
d'intérêt quand même.
C'est c'est du conflit d'intérêt.
C'est-à-dire, on nomme prétendument un
comité d'experts qui va cogiter, hein,
n'est-ce pas, qui va suffisamment
cogiter, c'est-à-dire qui en gros va
donner des arguments pour développer
cette automatisation de la vie, cette
désincarnation. Et quand même ce Yan
Lequin travaille pour Métaste et on
demande à des personnes qui sont aux
avant-postes du technolibéralisme de
cette systématique que je je ne cesse de
m'efforcer de décrire avec précision ce
soir avec toi, avec vous au nom de ces
personnes-là qui disent dans le monde en
le 28 avril
2023 que les systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle générative
vont organiser un nouvel âge de lumière
de l'humanité et on laisse parler cette
personne.
OK. sans contradiction.
Je reprends la parole. Donc là, je me
fais l'avocat du diable
une fois encore. Mais je t'en veux pas,
hein.
Donc je ne t'en veux pas.
On va se mettre à la place de nous de
nos gouvernants. OK. On a une population
grandissante de très pané.
Encore tu reviens sur ça.
On a un système éducatif de plus en plus
asbine qui ne remplit pas ses fonctions.
On a l'ascenseur social qui marche plus.
Oui,
on a des conflits géopolitiques, on a
des conflits énergétiques, on a des
problèmes de ressources, on a des
problèmes d'optimisation de nos
consommation. On est d'accord.
Oui. Cert, tu reviens à ça mais je par
moi j'avais pas pu terminer ma phrase.
Terminer par
Je t'en prie.
Je je je t'en prie. Donc là, on se
retrouve avec des gouvernants
qui sont coincés. Quand on entend
Christine Lagarde dire "Oh là là, on va
mettre de l'intelligence artificielle
pour comprendre d'où vient l'inflation.
Hier, on a fait une interview avec
monsieur Jacques de la Rosière, 94 ans,
grand monsieur,
je l'ai pas encore vu, tu m'en a
président président qui a été président
du FMI du trésor à Bangler France,
un vieux de la vieille, un puriste.
On se retrouve en fait avec des
gouvernants des grands corps pas
dimensionnés pour gérer la situation, en
panique,
grand corps. Des grands corps.
Des grands corps.
Hm hm.
Donc et toi tu arrives, tu dis "Non,
écoutez les gars, vous êtes en train
d'enlever tout flamme d'humanité, de
création, de de principes de création
et en plus tu aurais pu rajouter la
résilience de votre système s'il y a une
éruption solaire, qu'est-ce que ça donne
? On va se retrouver qu' ac des gars qui
savent faire un mil check avec des
pieds.
Donc
comment comment tu veux
aussi te mettre à la place des
gouvernants ? Ils ont hérité d'un
système qui marche sur la tête, qui a
rendu les gens de plus en plus stupides,
je ne dirai pas les choses comme ça,
égoïste, sans émotion, sans empathie
pour l'autre
et on se retrouve, il faut bien gérer
les choses.
Alors, on a compris d'abord, c'est pas
les gouvernants qui sont la cause de ça,
hein. C'est c'est un des vecteurs parmi
d'autres. euh les gouvernants que tels
que tu les appelles,
appelons appelons les appelons le monde
politique,
euh les élus, les démocraties libérales
euh euh sont euh imprégnés par une doxa
mais ça remonte à très très loin, que le
tournant libéral a permis de auquel il a
permis de donner presque une solution en
réalité des des solutions une solution,
des solutions et s'adosser à des à des à
des à des à des systèmes, à des
décisions, c'est celui de vouloir
procéder par plus grande efficacité,
hein, efficacité, le moindre désordre,
maximisation. On ne peut pas leur en
vouloir de cela. On ne peut pas leur en
vouloir. Le fait est que c'est allé à un
tel niveau parce que cela est à l'œuvre
depuis très longtemps mais c'est allé ce
qui singularise l'ordre
économico-politique depuis une
cinquantaine d'années, c'est que c'est
devenu la norme unique, c'est-à-dire la
recherche prétendue d'efficacité mais
pas seulement d'efficacité prétendue par
l'équation de pertes et profit
maximilisé.
C'est ça. C'est ça l'affaire. Alors cela
c'est, tu disais les grands corps, c'est
la grande norme, la grande norme
conceptuelle dans les grands corps
d'État, dans la technocratie,
dans le monde politique et dans le monde
des régulateurs et des démocraties
libérales. C'est pour ça quand Youveva
Larari dit les images qui vont être là
une distinction et cetera,
un historien du médiéval qui est devenu
d'un coup du jour au lendemain le un
spécialiste d'intelligence artificielle,
ça me fait rire. Bon mais ça c'est une
parenthèse. Il dit c'est un danger pour
les démocraties mais il se trompe
d'ordre d'un point de vue
méthodologique, c'est pas un danger pour
les démocraties, c'est que c'est les
démocraties libérales qui ont organisé
le développement de cette grande
mécanisme que nous décrivons ce soir
ensemble et qui fait que quoi ? Là, je
vais essayer de répondre en quelques
mots très précisément à la remarque et à
la question que tu me posais qui fait
que quoi qui fait que il y a un fait qui
est entériné, qui ne cesse de se
consolider, c'est que le monde
politique, le monde industriel et toute
une tout un air du temps et toute une
doxa. chantant d'OXA université, école
de commerce, monde du consulting
euh
suppose que ce mouvement en cours de
d'automatisation via des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle des affaires
humaines va entraîner une meilleure
organisation tendantielle
à tous les niveaux avec perte et profit
et plutôt plus de profit que de perte
tendantiel une meilleure organisation de
la société dans son ensemble tout en
générant quantité de profit qui vont
profiter au monde économique et qui vont
surtout profiter à quelques-uns enfin
quelques grands groupe et qui vont
ruisseler selon la fameuse euh formule
qu'on connaît qu'on connaît par cœur.
Ça va pisser
ça ça existe. Je vais dire ça ça existe.
Il y a le fait que nous
que il y a le fait que cette doxa là
elle est véhiculée.
C'est très compliqué. Elle est
véhiculée, elle est reprise par la
presse, elle est elle est reprise par
une très grande presse du monde entier
hein. C'est pas des méchants en disant
"Thier Breton a dit ça, attention, il y
a la régulation ou alors on va s'occuper
de telle chose ou alors
c'est le c'est le monde économique
lumineux mais on va voilà. Donc il y a
il y a une doxa qui entretient ces
dynamiques et puis il y a le fait que
dans nos esprits en société on a quasi
entériné c'est un peu d'une chose que tu
reprends par ironie Sky que tu enteriné
en disant oui mais si on n pas ça alors
on est déjà dans un tel une telle
désorientation on en a besoin quand même
pour faire certaines choses et bien
c'est là c'est là que je veux dire pour
terminer quelque chose au pluriel
extrêmement importante, c'est-à-dire que
nous avons oublié
à la fois la faculté de nous organiser
en communement
aux principes fondamentaux, mais pas
seulement, à nos aspirations, à nos
envies de nous organiser de telle
manière plutôt que de telle manière et
ne répondant pas et ne s'alignant pas à
ce modèle unique qui s'impose. C'estd ce
modèle là que je décrit, il est non
seulement unilatéral en étant repris par
nombre d'acteurs de la société
unilatéral c'estàdire qui ne vient, je
le redis, de quelques milliers d'une
poignée de quelques milliers dizaines de
milliers d'individus sur la planète. Il
y a 60 personnes qui détiennent la
moitié de la richesse mondiale.
Oui. Et encore je me parle de ça, je
parle d'une vision du monde, des
systématiques, des technologies qui
émane du cerveau extrêmement intelligent
mais quand même assez malade et cynique
de quelques dizaines de milliers de de
d'individus. C'est ça la dimension
unilatérale qui s'impose comme c'est ça
notre défaut de le croire comme un
modèle unique et qu'on ne puisse pas
imaginer qu'on en arrive même plus à
pouvoir imaginer d'autres modalités
d'existence mais aussi d'imaginer comme
les scénaristes de d'Hollywood
d'imaginer la possibilité au nom de nos
de nos critères fondamentaux de dire de
nous élever ce qu'ils ont fait de nous
dire ça va trop loin ça offense nos
principes ça offense la dignité
notre intégrité humaine, notre
créativité, notre intelligence et même
notre notre vision de la vie. Comment on
considère la vie, la flamme de vie qui
doit être dans une société et donc comme
dit Camu, vous allez trop loin et on
s'élève. Donc ce que je crois moi,
on fait quoi nous ? On fait ce que je
crois,
on fait une zone à défendre. Je
j'annonce une initiative ce soir.
J'annonce pour la première fois chez
toi,
chez Syerview, une initiative à laquelle
je pense c'est depuis des années, mais
que je vais mettre en place dans les
mois qui viennent et ça va se formaliser
et je ne serai pas seul et je et toutes
les les personnes qui sont intéressées
par cela sont bienvenues. On va essayer
de structurer cela relativement aux
experts, à l'expertisation de la société
par le haut. C'est on continue les mêmes
erreurs. On continue les mêmes erreurs.
C'est au moment où on parle de
réchauffement climatique, on parle de
dérive de management. On a on essae
d'évoquer tout cela aujourd'hui de de
recul de services publics. Qu'est-ce que
c'est tout cela ? C'est dû à quoi ?
C'est dû à l'expertisation de la
société. C'est-à-dire des personnes
prétendument sachantes, on dit à toute
la société en vue de seulement d'intérêt
privé de comment on devait nous
organiser. Et cette erreur, on continue
alors qu'on ne cesse de voir les dérives
décennies après décennies parce que le
tournant néolibéral
c'est le tournant de l'expertisation par
le haut de la société. Je le redis bien,
par le haut veut dire au nom d'intérêt
privé avec une vision du monde
strictement euh utilitariste et en
général en vue de répondre à des
intérêts de groupe industriel ou à de
nouveaux acteurs industriels qui
montent. Euh euh on continue la même
erreur. C'est comme si on apprenait pas
l'humain, tu vois, on on répète, c'est
ce qu'on appelle
en psychanalyse, tu vois comment on
appelle ça ? La la névrose, la
répétition. On se dit oui, on allait
trop loin. Réchauffement climatique,
management.
On nomme des experts, des prétendus
experts sur l'IA. On fait une régulation
de pensement qui n' qui n'a qui n'aura
aucune efficacité sur ce que je décrit
là. Je crois qu'il faut s'inspirer des
scénaristes et qu'il est temps de
monter, c'est ce que j'annonce ce soir,
un comité citoyen sur les technologies
numériques et l'intelligence
artificielle et les I génératives qui va
avoir quoi ? qui va voir au rat des
réalités quotidiennes les personnes euh
témoigner de ce qu'ils vivent plutôt que
de consensalement dans les journaux
interroger Yel Lequin, Cédric Vilani ou
Laurent Alexandre ou euh Thierry Breton
ou des personnes qui sont jugées parti,
qui ont une vision du monde et qui à
force d'interroger ces personnes euh
forge notre nos représentations nos
façons de faire comprendre les choses de
de comprendre les choses.
Il est temps que la société se parle à
elle-même. Je non mais je termine. Se
donne un miroir. C'est-à-dire, il est
temps que dans le management, dans les
entrepôts Amazon, dans le monde du
travail, dans l'école publique, dans les
hôpitaux, dans la justice, dans
l'administration, dans le monde du
commerce, bref dans tous les champs dans
l'aide aux soins, dans tous les champs
de la vie sociale, que les personnes
témoignent, fassent remonter des
technodis en disant "Ce n'est pas
exactement euh les choses ne se passent
pas exactement comme vous comme Comme
c'est raconté, il y a pas de grands
méchants loup par une grande doxa ultra
dominante et notamment la
complémentarité homme machine et
l'horizon lumineux qui est annoncé, ce
n'est pas exactement comme ça que se
passent les choses que nous allons vous
décrire, vous raconter par des
structures, par des par des instances
dédiées, faire remonter les témoignages,
ce que j'appelle une politique du
témoignage, les expériences vécues
depuis les réalités du terrain et qui
vont nous donner qui devraient nous
donner une autre intelligibilité des
phénomènes. et qui permettrait à la
société de mieux de mieux se déterminer.
Donc ce que ce que j'annonce ce soir, je
ne serai pas le seul. Ça se formisera
par une première grande réunion au
printemps où avec les syndicats, avec
quantité de forces vives de la société,
on va dire ces experts là, on en veut
plus. Nous, on va parler à partir de nos
existences, de nos principes, de nos
valeurs, de nos expériences, de ce qu'on
veut, de notre vision de la vie. Et on
va faire en sorte pas seulement de les
exprimer mais de leur donner une
efficace sur le terrain de nos réalités
quotidiennes.
Je te lis un commentaire qui n'est pas
une question qui est un commentaire.
Merci de pas me faire remonter la ligne.
Qui est un commentaire dans la partie
question mais c'est pas grave la lire je
vais lire quand même le commentaire. Je
ne suis pas d'accord du tout avec ce
qu'il raconte en médecine ce sera un
grand pas en avant. Il est très négatif.
Voyons les avantages et les et et
réglementons et appliquons les lois.
Bon,
cette tendance des Français de tout voir
en noir, je pourrais donner des exemples
fantastiques qui vont nous simplifier la
vie. Je suis handicapé et la technologie
actuelle m'aide beaucoup pour m'aider
encore plus.
Alors très bien, j'entends monsieur, je
vous entends parfaitement, j'en ai un
peu parlé. C'est-à-dire que avec la
médecine, je l'ai je l'ai théorisé, je
crois que j'en ai parlé en 2018 avec
toi, le fait est que j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure, n'est-ce pas, que des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
vont permettre
tant qu'on a la main de mieux concevoir
des des protocoles, de mieux concevoir
de mieux comprendre des phénomènes de
pandémie. Enfin, la liste est longue,
mais il y a aussi le fait que le
dans le la médecine, c'est une
gigantesque entreprise de privatisation
de la médecine et des systèmes de
diagnostic automatisés dont on nous dit
que ils vont bien mieux faire les
diagnostics que les que les que les
humains qui coûtent une fortune qui en
gros ne servent à rien hein. Mon cousin
est un éminent radio radiologue, il dit
tout ça ça ne sert à rien comme si je
faisais 51 heures de diagnostic tous les
jours et et on nous dit complémentarité
machine ça va laisser un peu libéré non
quand il y a une radio, on la voit on
diagnostique si on a des doutes on
appelle un collègue. Donc il y a aussi
le fait que il y a un business de ça de
je l'ai dit depuis 2016 c'est pas dans
l'hôpital public c'est pas des systèmes
d'intelligence de diagnostic automatisé
en a besoin. de soins, ces deux
personnels, ces deux matériaux adaptés
et puis on a vu la crise du Covid et on
a vu à quel point l'état de l'hôpital
n'était pas suffisamment adapté. Que
monsieur que j'écoute, que j'entends
disent, c'est pas c'est pas une vue
négative cher monsieur ce que je dis là,
qu'il y ait non pas des avantages mais
des choses qui peuvent développer en sa
descence sur ces systèmes. Mais qui peut
dire le contraire ? Je ne dis pas le
contraire, je reviens à mon équation de
de de
là on a la main et là on n pas la main
qui est une qui est une équation qui
nous regarde tous qui nous regarde tous
dans nos vies individuelles, dans nos
vies intimes, dans nos vies familiales,
dans nos vies collectives et en société.
C'estàd qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
société libre, plurielle
où les subjectivités parlent peuvent se
déterminer en commun et où la la flamme
de la vie et la flamme de nos
intelligences sont à l'œuvre. C'est
c'est cela c'est cela que je soulligne
moi. Et quand je te parlais de
cette phrase qui m'a donné qui m'a
vraiment
donné une claque enfin que j'ai trouvé
absolument merveilleuse,
qui m'a encore fait penser autrement au
plus loin euh certaines choses, c'est
Charles Peggy dans
notre jeunesse
qui disait qui évoque cette notion. Il
disait "Moi, c'est qui avec mes copains
de la quinzaine parce qu'il avait monté
une revue qui s'appelait les les cahier
de la quinzaine et il s'en prenait à
beaucoup de politiques qui trouvaient
que c'était des apothicaires en gros ce
que je dis des des des petits comptables
de la vie publique de la vie politique.
Dit pourquoi nous on s'en prend à eux ?
Pourquoi vous trouvez qu'on s'en prend
trop à eux ? Parce que nous c'est pas
cette vision de la politique
politicienne et et bassement
continuellement calculatrice.
Nous nous sommes dans une
nous défendons la dimension la notion de
mystique républicaine.
Oh mon dieu ! Quand j'ai entendu quand
j'ai lu cette phrase de mystique
républicaine.
C'est-à-dire la mystique républicaine
c'est la tension entre quelque chose qui
est plus grand que nous. Ne le tenons
même pas d'un point de vue religieux,
quelque chose qui est plus grand que
nous, qui est intangible, qu'on aime,
qu'on célèbre et le télescopage avec la
politique, c'est-à-dire nos affaires
humaines, la République, c'està-dire la
cause commune, les choses communes. et
que les choses communes, la cause
commune et bien dans sa plus grande
acception et dans la la plus grande
façon dont on doit la la tenir, la
défendre, c'est relativement à des
valeurs qui sont plus grandes que nous
et que nous devons défendre et célébrer.
Et je crois, juste pour terminer, je te
vois lever le doigt sur ce point-là. Je
crois je crois que ce qui nous fait
souffrir, ce qui a conduit au
réchauffement climatique, ce qui a
conduit à la psychiatrisation de la
société mais aussi ce qui a conduit à
l'automatisation croissance des affaires
humaines, c'est le déignier et l'oubli
de la mystique républicaine. C'est ça
que je crois. C'est-à-dire que à force
d'avoir tout fait passer par petit
profit, par petite perte, c'est-à-dire à
d'avoir euh euh entraîner une vision
misérablement
comptable de la société, on a non
seulement oublié d'autres modalités
d'existence qui nous revient, mais on a
fait le lit de tous les de tous les
dérives et de tous les mots dont on se
rend compte aujourd'hui de l'ampleur des
dégâts dont la la la le réchauffement
climatique, ce serait le plus évident.
Mais je voudrais dire une dernière chose
sur cela à propos de mystique
républicain et le fait que tu sais quand
il a dit ça Charles Pegy, on est en est
en 2023, n'est-ce pas ? 1920
1915, c'est-à-dire il y a un siècle. Si
si en société des êtres, des individus,
des politiques, des humains avaient
défendu cela, et bien c'est une toute
autre vision de la société qui aurait
prévenu. Et et cet été, je me suis donné
une vue de l'esprit. Je me suis dit,
vois-on voit-on imagine-on dans 3 4 ans
encore ce présent qui vient, imagine-on,
je donne un exemple, c'est facile, les
États-Unis ou le Royaume-Uni qui aurait
généralisé les les systèmes d'
diagénérative,
d'intelligence artificielle, de
tomatisation et désincarnation
croissante de la vie. Et imaginons un
autre pays Ron, un pays européen, la
France par exemple Ron et qui se serait
dit
on aurait un ministre des finances, un
vrai
c'est pas que finance et qui se et qui
se dirait il y a des choses qu'on ne
veut pas. Il y a des choses qu'on ne
veut pas. Les scénaristes qui
disparaissent, les profs qui
disparaissent, les avocats qui
disparaissent, les architectes qui
disparaissent. Et alors, je laisse-moi
terminer. Et alors, on se dirait on se
dirait dans 4 ans, voit-on cette société
? Et voitons cette société nécrosée,
impersonnalisée et voit-on cette société
lui encore de la vie où on cherche à
célébrer la vie. Et sur cela, je
voudrais dire un point important que je
théorise à la toute fin de la conclusion
de mon ouvrage, la vie spectrale.
C'est c'est au moment où on ne cesse de
célébrer le vivant, hein. C'est la c'est
la c'est la c'est c'est la chose qu'on
esse d'assaîner dans une forme, ce qui
me gêne, d'une sorte de d'adoration
quasi exclusive des éléments, hein, la
célébration du vivant dans le en général
le déni, l'ignorance ou l'oubli de
quantité de questions sociales et
politiques. Ça c'est une chose. Et je
crois que l'heure est au moins voire
aussi importante
de célébrer le vivant qui est en nous.
Le vivant duquel, n'est-ce pas, tu le
reconnaîtras et on le reconnaîtra.
Tout le tout le reste ne peut que
dépendre. C'est-à-dire comment voulons
comment pouvons-nous imaginer célébrer
le vivant, célébrer euh une dimension
écologique de la vie, une dimension euh
de sauvegarde et de célébration de tout
ce qui constitue le vivant d'un point de
vue organique, d'un point de vue de
force vitale, d'un point de vue de de de
génie de l'activité de de de l'esprit
humain. Si nous-même nous ne nous
donnons pas comme ordre, comme cier des
charges intangible de défendre mais
aussi de célébrer ce qui ce qui nous
anime ce vivant fondamental et ce génie
qui est en nous le promptisme
généralisé, ça va être de dire quoi ?
Face au réchauffement climatique,
donne-moi une solution. Et vous savez ce
qui va se passer ?
Tuer les vieux.
Non, comment
va pas tuer les vieux ?
Non, non, pas du tout. Non, non, non.
Ingénierie climatique. Et bah ouais. Bah
pourquoi ingénierie climatique ?
Tu es les vieux, ça coûte moins cher.
Ouais. Non mais mais pourquoi ? Non, il
faut bien comprendre ce que je dis.
Pourquoi ? Parce que tout à l'heure je
parlais de mots clés, c'estàdire ce
langage personnalisé, il va nous
conseiller ou nous orienter ou nous
inciter à faire des actes des actions en
fonction des mots clés achetés au plus
offrant par des sociétés qui auront le
droit d'être d'être mentionné. C'est ça
qui est à l'œuvre dans dans Bing et dans
Bard par exemple et qui seront à l'œuvre
dans plein de quantités de champs.
Quelles sont les solutions pour le
schéma pour le réchauffement climatique
? Au lieu de dire développer des
modalités vertueuses équitables qui
utilisent des modalités des matériaux et
des et des modalités qui ne tuent pas
les corps et les esprits et qui
défensent de la biosphère. Il va y avoir
des industries de l'ingénierie, du
climat et quantité d'industries de green
green washing qui vont proposer leurs
solutions. Donc, voit-on le fait que
l'automatisation
croissance et la désincarnation
croissante des affaires humaines, c'est
non seulement un renoncement
du vivant qui est en nous, mais c'est
aussi un obstacle. C'est ça que je veux
dire. Non mais non, tu as pas compris.
Je termine.
J'ai pas compris. termine cette phrase
mon cher un obstacle fait 25
à la célébration
du vivant qui est en nous et qui nous
revient aujourd'hui de célébrer plus que
jamais alors c'est cela qui est entamé
et c'est cela qui est mise en péril
parmi tant d'autres choses par
l'autométisation des résultats làdessus
il faut bombarder l'intégralité de la
population occidentale avec de l'AMD de
l'AMD
parce que les gens sont dans une
privation sensorielle à cause des
guerres des épidémies
ou non mais tu me répètes ça non moi je
parle de méthodologie par méodie
conduite introspective nécessaire à
prendre conscience
des facteurs tu viens d'énumérer.
Oui,
mais c'est surréaliste.
Et alors donc et alors on on baisse les
bras et j'arrête de faire des livres et
d'analyser les situations et avec
d'autres et donc on baisse les bras une
fois de plus. Non, je sais bien que tu
es dans l'ironie.
Non, il nous revient. Je te lis un
commentaire de d'ailleurs qui n'était
pas un monsieur mais une madame et je
vais continuer parce qu'il y a eu un
autre commentaire qui était intéressant
qui va te faire phosphorer un peu. Non,
c'est faux ce qu'il raconte, c'est faux.
Il réduit tout au profit capitalistique.
Capitaliste. On est tous là aujourd'hui
pour l'écouter grâce à la technologie.
Donc il faut écouter tous les autres qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec lui. Moi, je
suis ici aujourd'hui grâce à la
technologie. Je suis en vie grâce à la
technologie. On peut se faire des amis
ies virtuellement, échanger avec des
gens à l'autre bout du monde. On pourra
même échanger avec des êtres virtuels
plus gentils que les trous du cul qu'on
rencontre et qui nous nuisent et nous
empoisonnent la vie. Mais je suis
totalement d'accord avec madame à peu
près. Mais totalement d'accord. Sauf que
une fois de plus, on est sur les
risques, les risques et inconvénients
euh risque et avantages. Moi, je parle
là, on a la main, on n pas la main. Je
veux il j'ai j'ai été clair, on s'est
bien compris que le fait que l'âge de
l'accès, ce qu'on appelait l'âge de
l'accès nous a ouvert à quantité de
corpus, nous a ouvert à pouvoir
organiser des des relations
interpersonnelles au-delà des au-delà
des des continents, au-delà des méprises
physiques,
au-udelà de la vie. euh discuter avec un
mort
à des à des à des coûts toujours plus
marginaux. Oui, ça ça continue. C'est à
l'œuvre de ce qui a été nommé l'âge de
l'accès, c'est-à-dire au début de la fin
des années 90, au début des années 2000.
Depuis, chère madame, il y a une
vingtaine d'années qui se sont passées
et le grand phénomène qui s'est passé,
c'est ce que j'ai dit en amont, c'est
l'orientation algorithmique de la vie en
vue de marchandiser et de de situer
cette organisation toujours plus serrée,
organisée, hygiéniste. Et maintenant de
nous dessaisir avec notre propre
assentiment et notre propre passion pour
l'utilité, risque et le confort de nos
facultés les plus fondamentales. que
madame vous ayez affaire à cela et que
moi j'ai affaire au site du monde, au
site de la mais personne n'en doute. Ça
c'est moi je ne parle pas de cela une
seule seconde ce soir. Je ne parle je ne
suis pas dans cet environnement là
d'analyse. Je suis pas dans l'analyse de
qu'est-ce que ça nous permet l'accès via
des technologies numériques à à à des
dimensions de la vie humaine. Pas du
tout, en aucune manière.
Tu vas me conseiller trois bouquins pour
à lire pour la communauté. Alors pas les
tiens,
mais trois bouquins.
Tu sais, j'y pense là, je j'ai bien
entendu mais je pensais pas au bouquin.
Alors je pense je voudrais juste tr
films.
Non. Oui. Oui. Non mais je vais revenir
au bouquin.
Je je voudrais qu'au-delà du je suis
pour musique.
Je voudrais qu'au-delà de je suis pour,
je suis contre, je suis pas d'accord.
Je voudrais que qu'on suis pas qu'on
puisse ne pas être d'accord, que des
gens me suivent et il y en a beaucoup.
C'est pas, je dirais que c'est pas la
question du soir. C'est c'est pas ça qui
me préoccupe. Je voudrais que nous
puissions prendre la gravité, la portée,
prendre compte de la mesure de la portée
de la gravité, de ce qui de ce qui est à
l'œuvre, de ce qui se consolide, de ce
qui s'institutionnise et de plus en plus
en ne recueillant pas notre assentiment.
C'est de cela dont je voudrais. Je suis
venu pour cela ce soir. C'est ce que je
fais avec mon livre. Ma question c'est
trois bouquins
au-delà de je suis d'accord ou je suis
pas d'accord. Alors les trois bouquins,
j'en avais donné quelques-uns lors de
mes précédents passage. Ce sera celui
dont on a parlé en introduction
l'obsolescence de l'homme de Gunter
Anders. Un très grand livre qui est
remis, qui est relu aujourd'hui qui a vu
exactement ce que je viens de dire
l'ampleur de quantité de danger et et
dont il sentait d'ailleurs ça leur
disait des amis disaient ça commence à
le rendre fou. l'ampleur et le fait que
on ne se rendait pas compte de quantité
de danger et on se rend compte
aujourd'hui qu'on aurait bien fait de
l'écouter à plus d'un titre. Donc
l'obséescence de l'homme qui date, je
crois, de 1956,
hein. Lui, c'est un frère, un sens de
frère, frère humain et frère qui
m'inspire.
Je dirais
ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
au-delà de cette limite, vous ne la
passerez pas. l'homme révolté, Albert
Camu. Car ce que je viens de dire là en
final, il s'agit de ça. C'est juste de
prendre conscience que il y a certaines
choses qui vont trop loin. Au-delà de
notre petit avantage
immédiat et des petits avantages que ça
nous procure, voyons plus loin l'étendue
et voyons comment des des frères humains
vont être fracassés par ce mouvement qui
est à l'œuvre. Et engageons-nous nous
aussi pas que au nom de notre intérêt et
et mais au nom de de l'humanité ou de
notre condition. toute entière. Donc ça
c'est l'homme révolté hein. Au-delà de
cette limite, vous n'irez pas, vous ne
la passerez pas. Pourquoi ? Parce que
vous allez trop loin et ça fait offense
à nos principes qui nous qui nous qui
nous fondent et qui nous animent.
Et enfin, j'ai hésité entre deux
ouvrages
euh Paul Valéri, le bilan de
l'intelligence ou déjà une époque il y a
il y a fort longtemps, il y a plus d'un
siècle, il voyait à quel point la
rationalisation des sociétés
entamer quelque chose de la créativité
humaine, tiens, de nos intelligences. Et
je pense aussi à notre jeunesse Charles
Peggy qui a une conception de la
politique du politique dont j'ai dit qui
est grande, qui est qui est tout à son
honneur et qui devrait être tout à notre
honneur et dont le drame est qu'elle a
été oubliée, ignorée et avec lesquels
nous devrions reprendre plus que jamais
langue et nous inspirer.
Alors avant de te demander un conseil
pour les jeunes générations, je vais
lire un commentaire qui vient débarquer.
avant la fin demand pourquoi il n'aime
pas Aurélien Barreau. Tu aimes pas
Aurélien Barreau ?
Oh, c'est pas je vais pas répondre là.
Je vais pas répondre là. Non, j'avais
été gêné. Je veux pas que que le message
tout ce que j'ai dit ce soir, je
remercie monsieur de sa question et
créer un décentrement sur l'essentiel de
ce que je dis. C'est jusqu'à quelques
années, ça me gênait que comme tant
d'autres, je crois qu'il le fait moins,
on parlait vers les années 2015 du du
réchauffement climatique en continu via
les réseaux sociaux alors que ça
entraîne, ça ne cesse de contribuer au à
la consommation énergétique. Et je dis
aux jeunes générations qui ne cessent de
s'inquiéter du réchauffement climatique
allant jusqu'à la salastologie,
c'estàdire la panique du fait que nous
allons vers
des de plus en plus de difficultés que
nous vivrons d'un point de vue
climatique et environnemental
que c'est c'est je vous signale que
probablement un très grand nombre
d'entre vous font des promptes,
utilisent chat GPT et cela va induire en
terme de traitement de collecte de
et et d'usage continu des des des de la
consommation énergétique
corolaire gigantesque. Donc ce que je
dis c'est que c'était pour répondre à la
question de monsieur. Ce que je dis
c'est que mais c'est pour nous tous
moi-même je peux me l'appliquer he c'est
que la conscience ne se divise pas si on
a des grands principes si on parle
d'écologie je crois que il ne sert à
rien de de de de continuellement faire
part sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'urgence la grande urgence est de peser
sur le politique et de faire en sorte
que sur le le le la réalité de nos de
nos vies quotidiennes et bien on engage
des modalités d'existence qui célèbrent
le vivant mais dans toutes ces
dimensions, je viens de le
Écadin, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]